又到了一周一次和大家见面的时候了
我们这一节课讲完之后
后面又可以休息一周
想到这一点的话
整个课课程组就特别的开心
因为我每一周准备课程的时候
大家都非常的那个压力很大
那么我们压力很大
我怀疑我们同学们现在压力也很大
因为现在是不是考试季啊
我看到好多小伙伴在那个那个在弹幕里面说
这个考试考的怎么样
还有我们好多同学现在毕业
我觉得大家应该都是在为了自己的未来在努力
所以一起加油吧
然后呢在开始我们今天的课程之前的话呢
我先那个回答一下来自于我们社区的一些问题
那其实挺好玩的
真的每次我们的课程视频上上B站之后
那个后面的那个回复
就会有很多很有意思的东西
比如说有同学在问我们说
在哪可以问到我们游戏的那个
关于回答各种各样的问题啊
那么其实的话呢就是说在GITHUB上的话
还是要有discussion panel
那大家可以在里面的话
自由的去交流各种各样对小引擎的看法
或者我们关于引擎的问题
然后呢我们也拉了各种各样的微信群
然后呢我们有好几个微信群了
大家可以加到我们的微信群里面
这个微信群的话呢
在我们的课程官网上大家也能找到
因为在这些群里面呀
在这个就是群里面
我们的那个课程组的小伙伴都在里面
就是大家有什么问题的话
艾特他们
他们会尽可能就最快的速度
会转给我们这个课程组
还有各位技术的小伙伴
然后给大家尽可能尽快的回答
那么还有同学就问我们说
诶这个小引擎什么时候集成这个物理引擎
这个问题问的非常的到到到到位啊
因为其实我们这一趴是讲物理嘛
结果我们的小引擎没有物理引擎
所以呢我们在这个明天的更新中
我们会把物理引擎集成进去
这是一个我认为这还是很重大
很开心的一件事情
然后呢还有同学问我们说
希望我们提供更多的参考资料
比如说我们看的论文哪
看的这些这个代码这些讲座啊
这个问题提的我觉得这个需求提的特别的好
我们自己也在检讨
说我们只顾去准备课程啊
其实我自己有一个文件夹
里面快有100多篇论文了吧
就是因为在准备课课程的时候
我们的小伙伴就去找各种各样的资料
然后我还有自己要去看这些资料
那么所以呢在今天的课程中
我们专门在课件中留了大概4~5页
就把我们这一节课件的
所有的参考资料都放上去了
所以等同小伙伴们下载这个这节课程的
PDF的时候
就可以找到所有的论文和资料啊
非常谢谢小伙伴们给我的反馈啊
因为真的大家不提的话
我们完全意识不到这个需求
那么还有小伙伴问我们说
诶我每次听你们讲课程
然后的话呢就是说只是讲到一个一个的知识点
但是我不知道这一个个知识点是用什么道理
把它串起来的
我我需要把它编理解成一个故事
一个有逻辑的故事
才能方便我能理解这些知识点
其实这个问题问的其实蛮难的
因为我们在准备课程的时候呢
是花了很多时间去想我们讲什么
那个不讲什么
包括我们讲的顺序
先讲什么
后讲什么
最简单的去解释一下
就是说呃在整个课程准备过程中的话呢
我们一直在模拟一件事情
就是说假设我来需要写一个哎
能够做得出来游戏的这样一个游戏引擎啊
因为游戏引擎的知识点特别多
但是我们只挑说我做出一个基本的这样的一个
A功能齐全的游戏
我需要知道哪些知识
然后呢我们就按照这个flow
把整个知识点串到一起去了
然后呢这里面的话每个知识点的话
因为我们在课程中的话也在不断的调整
就是说尽量的避免讲到非常低调的一些算法
因为非常低调的算法
它讲解来是特别的细
一个个公式的推导
所以其实我们花了很多的时间
干一件什么事情呢
就是说把每一个知识点
我们提取它最难懂或者最核心的那一个点
我把那个点点通
因为我们的假设就是说
如果你真的要去实现这个东西的时候
你一定要去看他的原文
看看原文的时候
你会发现一上来很容易很容易看不明白
就像我上次讲课
说有同学看小引擎的时候看我们耀对吧
我就说你知道他的要点之后
你多看几遍
可能有一下子你突然就明白了
那这个东西你就get到了
所以呢课程上我们讲什么呢
我们就讲那个像衣服的领子一样
我就把那个领子那个地方把它拎出来
像今天我们要讲一个比较复杂的技术
像PPT其实它非常的复杂
而且数学上也很抽象
我其实我们是花了很久
我们写了大概有三四十页的PPT
然后最后凝凝练起来就这十页左右
但是实验的话呢
我们自己认为是把它最核心的思想给讲出来了
那么还有最后一个的话
就同学们问我们说诶
有同学问我这个很专业的问题
他就说哎我用了一个模拟擎
然后这个引擎在比如说移动端啊
PC上console上跑出来的结果都是不一样的
那么他想很想知道
说真实的这个游戏引擎里面的物理引擎
它到底在设备上怎么运行的
其实这个问题问的就很很有意思了
因为我们上一节课里面讲了一个概念
叫deterministic
实际上这个deterministic
就是同学的这个问题的一个答案
就是说其实就算是现在商业级的游戏引擎
它都没有办法保证在不同的硬件平台上
它跑出的结果是一样的
比如说因为你的iteration就迭代的不长
你的这个浮点数的精精度它都会有很大的差别
所以的话呢就是同一个引擎写出来的产品
在移动端就是我们的那个IPAD
那个IPHONE上面
比如说在我们的PC上面
在我们的那个XBOX上面跑出来的
演算出来的结果应该是不一样的
这个地方的话就是说我们需要做大量的处理
才能保证这个逻辑的一致性
所以呢这些就是对我们社区同学们的问题
的一个简要的回答
好那么在开讲课之前
第二件事情
也是这个也是给大家告诉一个好消息
就是明天5月31号
我们的最新的版本0.06版本也要上线了
那这个版本第一个呢就是刚才我已经剧透了
我认为是一个big move
就是说我们的joy我们接入了物理引擎
我们进入了一个比较简单轻量的物理引擎
叫joy
这个引擎虽然是很简单很清淡
我们挑了半天
我们觉得他足够的干净
足够的好理解
那么大家千万不要小看这个引擎啊
你们知道有一款大作就是这个啊
horizon就地平线
他用的就是这个物理引擎
所以你看看我们虽然写的是个小引擎
但我们跟3A大作用的是同一个物理引擎
大家是不是觉得很有牌面对吧
那么接下来的话呢这个是我个人的心愿
就是一我
我我上次看过我们小引擎的第一版的时候
我我就我自己苦恼了半天
我说哎呀
我们的这个rendering那一层做的太抽象了
然后就是绕来绕去绕来绕去
然后我们的课程组的小伙伴
这将近有花了两到三个星期的时间
认认真真的把我们的小引擎的rendering那一层
把它给清理的尽可能的干净了
那么那个后面的话呢
其实最新的代码我也没看到
但是的话呢就是等这个明天上线之后
我跟大家一起来看
然后我们看这个小引擎的这个新的代码
是不是更简单更好懂了
那么同时的话呢我们还修了一些bug
也非常感谢
就是我们社区的小伙伴
还有我们课程组的小伙伴一起做了满足的工作
其实在最近的这一个多月的话
其实我们课程组是花了蛮多时间去进行这种
就是我们的代码的优化的
因为我们现在因为一边在准备课程
其实没有时间去拍那个就是啊小引擎的讲解啊
或者准备这些更多的资料
所以我们就会对自己提个要求
就是尽可能的让小引擎就是让大家好懂
那这里面的话呢跟大家说一点
就是说我们大概把小引擎做到一个
功能基本齐全
然后的话呢代码足够清晰的时候
我们对它的更新会暂时告一
就是暂时缓一缓
因为我们不想把这个系统做的过于复杂
因为好多同学都是第一次接触
这么复杂的这个系统
所以如果我们功能堆得太多
搞得过于复杂的话
又会像我们一开始犯的错误样
就让同学们学习和进入起来就很难
所以也非常感谢就是大家给我们的反馈
因为没有大家的反馈的话
我们有的时候自己做错了都不知道
然后现在我们的课程开了将近两三个月了
大家给了我们很多反馈之后
我们慢慢慢慢的就课程也好呀
还有小引擎也好
市区也好
我们有点感觉了
知道怎么跟大家去互动啊
好
那最后就是正式的宣布
他在我们的这个小引擎的命名
这个活动终于告一段落了
那其实经过大家审慎的投票
那目前看到我们这个得票第一的名字是PICO
对吧
这个单词其实我也不知道
你看我我在美国呆了那么多年
居然这个单词我也不知道
后来那个课程组告诉我说哦
这个叫短笛的意思
就代表我们的引擎短小精悍
然后我觉得这个名字挺可爱的
比如说PICO
Pico low low low low low
我可以搭很多漏
而且更好的一点是
他可以重用我们以前设计的那个P的
那个那个icon
我不知道那个P的icon会不会给别人撞啊
反正anyway就是既然是落子无悔了
社区的同学们已经选了这个名字
我管它是什么名字
我们就用了吧
那那就是说啊
如果大家没有反对的意见的话
那我们就把我们的小引擎升级成PICO
但是可能有些东西在那个重命名啊
特别是代码重命名可能需要花一点时间
我不知道GITHUB上能不能remake啊
说不定不能ren anyway
就是说啊至少我们有一个名字了
这是根news好
这些就是今天和大家
那个就是我们我们一些反馈
那我们接下来就开始我们今天正式的课程
就是物理引擎的第2part
今天呢讲的是物理引擎的应用
其实呢也是很多很高级的一些应用
就是物理引擎到底怎么样子
在游戏的这个场景里面实战起来
那么上一节课呢
我们讲了物理引擎的很基础的一些概念对吧
告诉大家了什么
就是说哎read the body
动力学是什么
怎么怎么做的
我们知道CLICHINTECTION怎么算呢对吧
其实到这个地方是有点高能的
我知道那像SHRESOLUTION的话呢
实际上我只是点了一下
根本没有展开那个算法
那个算法其实非常的dirty
有很多的细节在里面
那么像SQUIRY啊
像其他的一些物理的东西的话呢
我们都点到了
那其实最核心的就是大家知道
就是说那个牛顿力学simulation的基础算法
几个欧拉的显那个显影视积分对吧
欧拉的这个这个这个就是说显示积分
欧拉的半隐式积分
这些东西都是非常重要的一些概念
包括那个刚体动力学的旋转对吧
我们还记得例句对吧
我们知道它的转动惯量
知道他的这个角角动量
那个动量这些概念
这些概念其实非常的重要
那么我们有了这些基础的概念
我们有了这些基础的server之后
实际上接下来的话呢我们就看怎么去应用它
所以今天的话呢给大家讲一些
我们的应用的场景
那首先第一趴呢就是这个character controller
就在这个物理世界里面
我们的角色到底是怎么动的
大家会觉得很简单
角色不是就是我自己动一动就可以了嘛对吧
然后但是问题是你是在一个物理的世界里面
你的运动和这个世界到底什么关系呢
那首先大家想到动的话
我们首先想到的是什么呢
哎dynamic object
动态物体
对不对
我这个我我在physical engine里面有动态的东西
那我就放个动态的东西嘛
但事实上的话呢
character control它不是这个概念
就是说如果我放了一个dynamic object的话呢
它实际上是有它的质量
它有它的摩擦力
虽然他非常的真实
但是呢它和人的控制的直觉
是有很大的不一样的
就是你站在地上
你不会意识到说我在地面上是有是有摩擦力的
你会觉得我我想站哪
我就站在那儿对吧
所以在我的认知世界里面
我们认为我们和地面的摩擦力几乎是无限的
而且呢我们也不认为我们自己是个弹性体对吧
我们认为我永远是紧贴着地面
而且呢我们的加速转向
甚至我希望有teleport
teleport的意思是什么呢
我是一个魔法
打个响
指从A点到B点
所以其实呢character control它是一个反物理系统
而不是一个真实的物理系统
所以还记得上一节课我们讲的就是说actor
有一种叫做叫做topic actor
对不对
那condemic action的话呢
实际上character control
就是他一个很典型的一个应用
在这里面它是反物理的
你看到这里面那个小绿人站在这
无论什么东西撞它
它都会把它弹开
这就是我们的character control好
那么为什么会有这个东西呢
其实最早啊
其实早期的游戏没有真正的物理引擎
那我们作为game developer
我发现一件事情
就是说我们如何去让这个游戏里面角色的行为
符合我的认知的时候
其实我写了大量的hack的代码
比如说多少度坡你能爬的上去啊
我当我开始起跑的时候
我的加速度应该什么样子
我停下来应该是一种感觉啊
我撞到墙之后
这个人应该是什么反应啊
这些大家会觉得诶这不是很简单吗
就比如在真实世界里面
我们和世界的交互就是这样的
但是呢在游戏世界里
你会发现这些东西
每一个细节你都会去需要单独处理
在这里面呢我就不展开
待会儿我给大家讲CTRL的时候
你会发现讲完一个最简单的control的概念
但是你会发现有很多种特殊的情况需要处理
这些情况你不处理的话
当你做成一个游戏的时候
你玩起来就会觉得很奇怪
所以这节课这一趴的话呢
讲的是一个非常时尚的
只要你作为一个游戏
只要游戏里没有主角的话
你基本上就需要知道这些概念
那么好
首先我们讲这个control怎么去构建
实际上也比较简单对吧
我们就用一个刚才讲的CONNEC的一个actor
我构建了一个一个一个东西
把我自己包起来
那一般做什么形状呢
我们知道可以用一个box
我们也可以用一个图包对吧
但实际上呢至少在我看到很多产品里面
大家用的比较多的是什么
是个胶囊诶
这个胶囊就很有意思了
你仔细看那个胶囊啊
它有两层
一层是外面一点的
稍微肥那么一点
一层呢是小一点的
小一点点的干什么事情呢
就是我真的跟别人去撞了
就是我撞到
那而那个外面那一圈是什么呢
你可以认为它是一层保护膜
它防止你去离别人的东西太近
当你高速移动的时候对吧
如果我那个胶囊一不小心就卡进去了
我就卡住了
这是一个用处
其实还有一个用处是什么呢
就是如果你想想看我们的游戏
就是大家如果学过图形学的话
知道我们的相机有个什么东西叫做镜平面对吧
那么当我做第一人称射击的时候
如果我的角色撞了离那个平面太近的时候
是不是会出现你看到墙背后的东西的
这样的一个bug
我不知道大家有没有玩早期的一些游戏啊
你经常会发现就当你的脸贴墙足够近的时候
你看到墙背后的东西了
实际上这一层保护呢
它也是防止就是角色离墙太近
这样的话很多时候相机也会产生的bug
但相机其实更复杂了
有时候我们相机会做一些叫相机碰撞
那么我有了这个东西之后
这个角色可以在环境里移动了
对不对
但实际上它一个比较复杂的东西是什么呢
就是我在运动中
我当前的位置是X对吧
我变成X加一的时候
哎我实际上可能被一个东西撞着
撞住之后呢
我们天然的想法是阻挡就停在那儿
对不对
但实际上人人的perception
或者我们人的天然认知是什么
你应该沿着墙去划一下
这个时候你要去写一个叫sliding的一个算法
在这里面你看这个角色他已经走到墙上的人
你会发现他虽然脚往前迈
但整个人横移
如果你们现在玩几乎所有的这个游戏的话
无论是3A还是一般的游戏
基本上都会做这个系统
所以说大家如果实现自己的character controller的话
诶这是你必须要写的一个东西
我记得我在第一趴讲课那个小引擎的时候
我就想哎我们一开始没有做物理
所以我们的人到了墙上的时候
它还不能sliding
其实就是这个功能我们还没有实现
那么第二个的话呢
就是说其实在真实的环境中
我没有办法保证整个游戏环境
它都是那个连续的
我们会最经常遇到的东西是什么呢
是台阶
那么我们就要让这个角色他不会
比如说有一个几厘米高的一个障碍物
我一个半2米高的人走不过去
这是很不科学的
对不对
所以呢stepping
其实也是一个非常重要的一个角色系统
那这个东西怎么做的呢
其实就是当我每一次每一帧
我要移动这个角色的时候
我就会尝试把这个controller诶
往高台那么一点点往前走
那这里面就会产生一些很有意思的bug了
我不知道大家以前在游戏游戏里没有遇到
就是如果设计师没有设计好
他那个屋顶设计的稍微矮那么一点点的话
我们就会把角色卡进去
我记得我以前在做这个halo的时候
我刚去的时候
我的设计师就会告诉我们的设计师
就会告诉我说
我们在做所有的门的时候
都比正常人要通过的门要大大一点
大大概大概30%到40左右吧
他就为了防止这个这个角色被卡在
那个门的入口的地方了
所以其实这个地方的话就是刚才我刚才讲的
这里面有很多的这个HARDCODE
但这个东西非常的重要
因为你其实当我们在做一个游戏的时候
我们是希望用户的体验非常的自然和流畅
所以out stepping的话呢
也是一个非常重要的一个系统
一个一个也不叫系统
就是非常重要的一个feature
你必须在你的control里面去实现
还有一个是什么呢
就是说哎我们看到一个斜坡
我们下意识的反应是什么
我要冲上去
所以呢当你去设计这个control的时候
一般我们都会设设定一个叫做你的MAXIPHONE的
这个这个slope的角度
就是当你的角
当这个slope
就是这个这个坡度大于某个角的时候
他就开始滑了
哎注意啊
他不是上不去
它是你可以跳上去冲上去
它还给它滑下来
所以这里面其实是蛮有点就是很有意思
就是说他又有那么一点点物理的感觉
它又不完全物理
如果我们在动画系统做的更加的精细的话
大家还记得上次我们在讲动画系统讲课
说动画系统有个叫ASM对吧
就animation machine
那么大家仔细想想
一个人如果冲上土坡的时候
他的那个脚的动作其实做的精细的话
不应该是用走路的动作
对不对
他有一种尝试往上去攀岩
然后呢当它往下滑步的时候
他要尝试去那个就踹两下
保证自己不要这个这个这个摔下来
所以其实啊
大家如果想表现一个
非常活灵活现的一个人类角色的话
你会发现无论是这个物理系统还是动画系统
有很多的细节在做
所以呢这个slope也是一个非常重要的设置
如果电动用不设置
会发生什么情况呢
你会发现这个人会飞檐走壁了
在游戏世界里面
它就可以沿着那个沿着一个你看起来80度
90度的悬崖
他就一路就蹭上去了
我相信这个东西的话呢
在其实在就算是3A游戏里面
也是个非常常见的一个bug
我知道很多的B站上的视频都是给你展示说
如何利用这个物理的bug
沿着墙一路就跑到地图边界之外对吧
或者爬到一个极高的地方
那个地方本来我们都不应该爬得上去的
实际上这也说明就是说
其实你想做好一个好的control的话
事实上还是蛮复杂的
所以当我们去写我们的这个小的游戏的时候
我们的引擎一定要提供
这个就是slope limit的设置的功能好
那其实呢这里面还有一个很重要的细节
就是说这不叫细节
其实我认为也是很重要的
一个一个一个在我们实现character controller
要注意的东西
这个地方其实我自己当年都写出很多的bug
就是说当角色他有很多姿态
比如说大家如果玩一个射击游戏
我们的角色有多少姿态
比如说站着射击
对不对
还有什么呢
还有我半蹲着设计对吧
还有什么
还有最猥琐的
比如说我要当一个这个这个狙击手的话对吧
我们叫做老鹰对吧
我们就趴在地上
我们就那个时候你的controller
它其实形状是要发生变化的
否则的话它会就会出现叫做诶
你明明觉得我能通过
但是你就是过不去的情况
那这个时候呢有一个很重要的实施方式
就是比如说一个人在通过管道的时候
他蹲在那儿对吧
他这时候突然发出来一个站起来的指令
那个时候你千万不能一上来就把他的control更新了
因为你一旦更新之后
物理他很多运算实际上它是瞬间的嘛
那你在做下一步迭代的时候
他会认为你的controller就已经卡在这个管子的
比如像刚才那个tunnel
那个隧道的不上不下的地方
你就动不了
你就说你收也收不回来
你往前往后
他的认为物理计算机都认为你被卡死了
其实在很多的游戏中
我们会出现角色做一些动作被卡死的情况
其实就是在这些时序上出了问题
所以character controller
他讲的所有的东西都非常的简单
但是的话呢如果你不仔细的去做它
当你面对一个非常复杂的这个
游戏的environment的时候
你就会产生无数的bug
这也就是为什么游戏QA压力很大
也是个原因
就是因为它实际上基础原理讲起来都非常简单
但是的话呢在游戏的世界里面
各种各样的情况非常的多
那接下来再讲一个这个大家啊
这个还比较简单
就是说其实character controller呢
它实际上和环境还是有互动的
比如说我们碰到那种各种dynamic的物体的话
我们实际上是把它推开
那怎么推开呢
其实很简单
就是character controln呢
一般来讲如果你用的是物理引擎
它会告诉你一些回调函数
说哎不好意思
我抓了某某某
这个时候呢你可以根据自己的速度
根据自己的这个字
你觉得我的重量输出去一个冲量
这个冲量的话呢
apply到这个物体上去
那其他的物体就能被推动
这个其实是我跟环境的互动
但这里面环境互动一个
我认为比较容易出问题的地方是什么
就是如果你的controller是站在一个动的东西上
因为刚才我们所有的demo它的环境都是静态的
对不对
但如果环境本身是动的呢
比如说一个platform
大家想想看
我们在一个物理的解散环境里面
我放个control下面的平台
在动的时候
我们好像没有什么约束约束
他不会维持自己的状态
所以说如果你不去做特殊处理的话
那个角色他就会当那个台子冻掉之后
诶这个角色就掉下来了
其实我以前在做很多游戏
比如说我们做一个巨大的飞船对吧
那个飞船的话他要往前飞或者往上下飞
其实上下也是一样的
就是上下的时候呢
你会觉得诶动的时候
上面的这个角色因为物理的约束它会比较顶
对不对
但是你会发现它这个物理的结算
它是有一个就一帧左右的这样的一个波动的
你会发现那个角色就会一直这样
当当当当当
就是说台子深一点啊
他被顶上来
台子上来他就被顶上来
它之间总是有一帧的这种误差
所以实际上像这种情况下
我们要用recast
就是我们要检测说你到底是站在哪一个平台
那个平台如果是动的话
大概率也是个物体好
你说我现在就站在这个物体上了
那这个时候呢
我们一般就会把它两个逻辑上绑在一起
所以除非你有更多的就你有新的移动的输出
那我就会是head cut code
保证这个control和这个被就是你step on的这个物体的
相对关系不会发生变化
所以这个地方是个完全的hack
但是的话呢这件事情对物理引擎其实蛮重要的
当然有同学会讲说这个好耶
听上去很粗暴啊
比如说我的一个台子突然加速对吧
我这个人好像站立不稳
会摔倒
甚至会掉下来
这种情况也是合理的
你说的没错
这种情况确实是合理的
但是呢如果我们要做到这种精细度的话呢
我们需要专门的去写
专门的去处理
所以其实我觉得对control这个东西的总结是什么呢
就是它没有什么特别难的技术
但是呢它有无数的小细节
而且呢每个小细节你都是通过各种各样
你自己认为这个角色该怎么运动的一个处理
所以我认为它是cut code
但是呢你会发现他又和用户的这种感受
是直接相关的
所以一个游戏
比如说我们经常讲的它的操作感对吧
它的移动感其实就已经被定制在这儿
比如说你去玩一个魂系列游戏对吧
那你们角色的移动
和你玩一个像那个荒野大镖客
那种很写实的游戏
那个角色的移动和环境的感觉对吧
和你玩一个像SUPERMARIA或者sonic
这种非常快速的游戏
那种角色的感觉是完全不一样的
而这种difference的话呢
其实有很大一部分是来自于我们在control上的
实现了不同
所以当我们做个引擎的时候呢
我们需要把这些接口都开放给我们的开发者
让他们来去TK他自己想要的这个角色的style
所以这是control
这也是我们真正用起来
物理世界的这个第一趴好
那么第2part是什么
也是大家经常会遇到的东西
就是RAGDO
翻译成中文叫什么叫布娃娃系统对吧
我一直觉得这个名字翻译的特别的萌
就是让我觉得啊
我我总是我脑子中
总是想象一个这个五颜六色的
彩色的一个布娃娃
然后就在这个游戏室里搬来搬去对吧
但anyway这个没关系
这个反正我们知道RAGDOLL是什么就可以了
这只是我刚刚学这个概念的时候
我脑子里出现了一个很奇怪的幻想
那这个RT系统啊
其实对物理引擎对这个游戏世界非常的重要
为什么呢
因为其实我们很多动画都是假设环境是预定的
但真实的在游戏的environment里面的话呢
它的环境是很复杂的
那这时候你会发现说
如果我只是播放动画的话
这个角色他的行为
它实际上跟环境是没有一个互动关系
就像这个face里面
就是说假设我们做了一个就是啊2assassinate
就是说刺杀的这样的一个动画组
一般来讲这种动画呢是是双人动画
就是说两个人在同时播一个动画
当我的攻击者的动画播完没关系
他站在那儿对吧
但是我被攻击者
他被assassin玩
就是被刺杀完之后呢
他应该会失去意识
这个时候他如果只是播放他的
这个就是被机动画的最后一帧的话
当你在一个悬崖边或者在一个斜坡上的话
他整个人就僵在那儿
就会如果这个斜坡啊
这个情况会更糟糕
你会发现他整个人斜插在那个那个坡上
感觉非常的违和
而这个时候你就需要RAGDOLL系统接管
让这个人像真的一个失去意识的肢体一样
自己就摔下去了
那这样看上去很真实
讲解一下我们的最右边的这个动图
大家看到的东西
那么瑞克多怎么做呢
其实大家学完了动画那一趴
rock door其实也并不是特别难理解
就是说哦那我明白了
我不是有很多的join吗
join之间那个有很多的骨骼对吧
那好我呢就是把这些关键性的joint
用一个大的这个ragile body把它连起来
注意啊
这里面比如说我一个角色身上的骨骼
可能有三四十个
甚至是七八十个
但是呢我们因为RAGDOLL的做的时候呢
我要让它的计算不要过度复杂
所以rog do一般不会太多
最多也就十几个吧
也就这么多了
所以呢它基本上是一个比较模糊的
这样的一个表达关系
就这里面的话蓝色的区域就是大家看到的
就是说一个个的RT body是最右边的话
那一个蓝色区域
那个红色的点就是我们选中挂RAGDOLL
就是其实我们一般用两个joint之间连了一个
就是reheal body
看这些register body通过那些join连在一起的话
诶就是我们的这个那个RAGDOLL的整个的核心
计算的这个物理对象
那么在这里面的话呢
其实哎我们复习一下
在上一节课应该是上上节课讲动画技术的时候
我们就讲到就是说joint每个joint啊
它实际上是有一个constrained
那为什么有constrained
这符合人体的解剖学原理对吧
比如说像我们的手
我们是只能这样运动
这是HG对吧
但是呢实际上我们好像还可以这样移动对吧
这个这个移动好像是用这块的技术
还是谷歌
Anyway
就是说其实我们每一个joint它的类型
它的自由度实际上并不是完全的六自由度
实际上很多时候连三自由度都达不到
它是严格的被约束住的
那这件事情呢对于rua do来讲解非常的重要
因为动画师啊
他去首K的时候
他脑子中是有一个人体的动力学意识的
他不会乱做的对吧
但是你当你把这东西交给我们的
物理引擎的时候
物理琴说我才不知道呢
你如果告诉我说这只是一群被关节连
就被一些胶链连接在一起的这些沙袋的话
那我可以给你冻出各种很妖娆的姿势出来
那这里面就有一个example
你们可以看到就是说
当我们用一个点拎着一个角色的时候
左边的这个他是设置了正确的
符合人体解剖学的join
你看到他的他这个动作看上去还是比较自然
Huali
对不对
右边那个就是OK你们都是链接连在一起了
你看这个动作看上去就比较妖娆了
对不对
如果大家如果回想一下
很早期的一些低成本的游戏的时候
你们会经常看到这种很有趣的这个人体的行为
不过说实话我个人还是蛮喜欢这个设计的
因为这让我想起了一个我很喜欢玩的游戏
大家能回想起来吗
人类一败涂地对吧
他那个joy就是很灵活的把joy设置了一遍
结果让我得到了一种前所未有的一种喜感
但anyway
但是我们今天讲的是正经的啊
我们讲的是正经的3A游戏的这个jolt怎么做
所以呢咱们就得学一些正经的这个joint
怎么去加他的约束
那么其实join的约束呢
大家也不要特别担心
实际上在现在的这个所有的DCC工具里面
以及设计设置rock豆的每个join的时候呢
它实际上把全部的六个自由度全部开放给你了
但是呢你可以在里面通过约束的方式实现
就是你各种想要的说我
我限制他只能做这个轴向的旋转
或者只能做HG的这样的一个一个翻转
或者像一个那个
就是比如说像那个那个那个什么B的那种方式
只能去旋转
其实实际上的话呢
就是他现在的很多设置都是全部开放给你
你自己来约束它
但这个东西的话呢
实际上就是在我们真实的这个游戏引擎里面
特别是我们这些joint的约束
我们尽量不会让所有的美术同学去做
因为很多时候对他们来讲太抽象了
我们一般会交给谁呢
大家可能听说过这个工种叫做技术美术工种
这帮都是一个又懂比较懂技术
同时呢在美术方面经验也比较比较
那个就是啊比较久的同学
它能够细条
根据我们对人体结构的理解
细条每一个rag dog join的约束
那这个时候其实调的好啊
调得不好
其实差别还是挺大的
这里面就有个例子
其实无论是左边右边啊
这两个约束条的都还OK
但是呢当你细看的时候
你会发现如果调的不够准的话
这个人在地上就会有各种各样很奇怪的东西
就是要么这个胳膊就钻到地下去了
要么就这个人的姿态看着非常的不能贴地吧
我们就不能贴地
所以说呢其实rag doll的话呢
一般来讲你设定好绑定好这些joint的约束
做好之后呢
在整个游戏生命周期里面
我们一般是不会动它的
就是把它放在那儿了
好那这里面其实就讲一个很有意思的事情啊
就是说大家刚才看的就是RAGDOLL
实际上我们大概只有
比如说十根不到的这个这个register body对吧
去动我整个body
当我身体上有几十根的这种骨骼
那我因为我的skinny animation
是基于我的skeleton去做的
对不对
所以其实这里面还有一部反向的映射
就是说我怎么把布克多的这个动作
映射到我的skeleton上去
大家还记得我们在上一节课讲animation的时候
我们曾经讲了一个概念
我不知道大家还记不记得
叫做animation retargeting
就是说我把两个骨架不同的动画互相映射
大家想想看
其实我从一个reactor算出来的结果
反向的去驱动一个skeleton的话
是不是一个animation retargeting的问题
其实他用的思路就是这样一个思路
就比如说我们去看人体这个这个角色身上
完整的skeleton里面的骨骼的话
有些骨骼呢实际上是和RAGDOLL完全重合的
我们叫做active jolt对吧
他就是参与了我的整个actor的那个那个
RAGDOLL的这个运算
还有一些是什么呢
就是是在我最后一根那个RKO的那个
那个骨骼之外往外延伸的
比如说我们用rock do做到这个手的胳膊这个地方
那手掌之外的这些骨骼
像这些骨骼
你原来是什么pose
我就放在什么的
我就不动你了
反正就是你这个动了
我就跟着动对吧
我就这些这些这些东西叫什么呢
我们叫做leaf joints
那就继续进行延伸就好了
但是呢比较麻烦的是什么呢
诶在两个就是在一个就是那个RAGDOLL
richard body里面的话呢
它中间还有很多跟过渡性骨骼
大家还记得我们在讲那个animation
RETARGETING的时候
其实我们有很多方法对吧
就是说诶我可以根据你的动作
我把这个动画呢这个这个pose
这两个pose之间一路的差值过去
然后均匀地分散到各个谷歌上去
实际上在这个地方的话
那么ary targeting
就是一个非常重要的这个应用场景
所以中间那些joint我们叫做intermedia joint
那么它的pose实际上是同前后两根REACD的
那个pose之间的差值出来的
这个方法的话呢
就能够把整个skeleton由rad来驱动
所以这个就大家刚才看到所有的demo
他就是用这个体系做的
那么RAGDO呢在真实的引擎实现中啊
有一个细节就是说
其实呢他不可能永远是rock door的
我们看到的角色大部分都是什么呢
都是动画驱动的
所以它从动画到rock dog之间是有一个过渡的
大家仔细看一下这个case里面
其实他前面可能百分之就是之前那个动画
大概播到70%到80的时候
诶我们一般不会到最后一帧
我们说哦这个人已经这个失去这个角色
已经失去知觉了
哎我们开始慢慢慢慢的可能到最后一帧
最后一帧前把整个动画全部切到RAGDOLL
所以刚才你发现就当这个骨骼变成红色的时候
就是我们开始把整个运算交给了物理运算
那么这里面其实就引入了一个
非常有意思的概念
就是动画和物理仿真之间的边界在哪里
其实这也是现代游戏引擎啊
特别注重的一些一个实现的一个细节
这个细节的话直接影响了你的角色活灵活现
所以这里面的话呢
今天我给大家就点一个概念
就是power record
就是说
实际上刚才像刚才那个刺杀那个例子里面
其实在RAGDOLL和animation
之间有一个很明显的分界线
对不对
但实际上在我们的现代游戏中啊
很多时候我们是把动画和物理混合在一起用了
为什么呢
因为举荐里面的一个例子
就这个主角他抱着一个小女生
这个小女生晕倒了
那么这个小女生晕倒呢
如果我完全的交给物理去做
大家想想看小女生晕倒
他是不是那个没有意思的对吧
当你移动的时候呢
这个小女生的手就开始各种甩
但是你会发现他甩的特别像
很很不真实
因为那时候是个小女生
只是昏倒了
所以你看这个中间那个结果看上去就很奇怪
那么如果呢我用二
我要我让那个artist
去专门做一个小女生的这样的一个动画
那个动画里面的话呢
你会发现就是说他的pattern是非常repeat的
就是说虽然你做的很有表现力
很符合那个就是半昏迷状态的一个女孩子
但是他整个过程中
实际上这个这个这个角色看上去就是看久了
就会觉得很重复
所以这个时候啊
实际上我们是会把物理的输出和动画的输出
之间作为一个互相的一个blending
这个讲解起来就比较复杂了
其实我们可以认为就是我们要动画输出
作为他一个初始状态
把它作为一个数
因为动画不仅提供了一个pose
还提供了什么
提供它的速度
它的转动惯量
我们把这些东西呢放到我的物理结算里面去
再结合它整个这个角色在空间上的这个位移
哎我再给它产生一个新的光亮和角动量对吧
这个时候我物理算出个结果
然后呢我在物理和动画之间再进行一个差值
这样我一帧帧的动画播放
我在一帧帧的物理模拟
这样我能产生一个看上去又像一个人类的行为
但又符合又有点物理的失控的感觉
这个例子呢还有更好的一个例子是什么
我不知道大家以前有没有玩过那个新战
就是33A大作版的那个就是主机版的性价
中间有一种东西
就是你把那个你用超能力把一个人给举起来
你领的那个那个就是
比如说帝国战士的那个脖子
那个帝国克隆战士的话
他就会开始就各种挣扎
你可以把他这样拿到左边
拉到右边
你会发现这个角色他自身的也有自我的意识
但是当你去把它往左边去移动的时候
他的身体会不由自主地往另外一个方向去甩
而这个时候如果完全用动画去做的话
那动画是会累死
那怎么办
诶
我这里面就是用这种power recordo
在动画和物理之间来回的去去去blending去过渡
所以这个其实也是我自己个人还蛮看好的
一个就是在引擎里面的一个实现
因为随着我们对游戏品质要求越来越高
我们越来越不满足于就是说动画是预先设好的
这个循环的animation loop
我们更希望就是环境用户的输入
给角色的行为带来更多的随机性和多样性
所以的话呢
rag doll是一个很重要的一个基础系统
但是在他之上的话
有很多很有意思的东西可以去衍生
那RAGDOLL的话呢
我们就讲到这儿
那接下来的话呢也是我们的物理系统
最重要的一个大客户啊
这真这真真实实是我们物理系统的大客户
就是我们的医疗系统
因为其实怎么说呢
就是现代游戏这个对于人物的
其实我们今天讲的虽然是意料
但是大家如果想了解一下
比如人物的毛发对吧
然后跟这个东西很接近
但毛发比它更复杂
毛发是一丝一丝的
我我在一开始讲课就毛发
我们我们在课程中不展开讲了
因为那玩意儿讲起来又是又是一堆东西
但意料的话呢跟他有一些异曲同工之妙
那么实际上我在我看认为啊就是一个角色
你去看他怎么样真实
他其实整个角色你把它建模做得非常的细
做得非常的真实
但它是静态的
你怎么觉得他是活的呢
我觉得第一个是他的表情对吧
他的表情让你觉得很真实
第二个呢就是哎她的头发
当她回眸一笑
他的左摇
他的头发微微动
那个一个小刘海的波动文化
你觉得哇这个角色很可爱对吧
那这里面二次元的这个同学们应该很懂
我在讲什么
还有一个是什么呢
就是医疗
因为医疗太实在是太重要了
就是你这个小姐姐的衣服好不好看
实际上就是在看你在游戏中的这个角色的衣
衣服模拟的是不是足够灵动
那么其实医疗呢从最早期的做法
其实想象的非常的简单
什么呢
哎我们就用动画去做对吧
你不就是这个走走
让他一些东西飘一飘嘛
我在里面买几根骨骼
还大家还记得我在讲动画
一开始就讲课
就是说其实很多游戏
特别是早期的游戏啊
他给标准的角色上埋了很多骨骼
有些谷歌就是用来做衣料的飘动的
比如说以前大家会觉得诶
我的游戏里面有那种披风对吧
那披风怎么动的
1000就是放了三条骨骼
然后呢衣料往上一放
诶这个衣料动画是做好了
当我跑走的时候
这个衣料比如比如说你往左边跑
往右边跑
诶这个骨骼相应的就变一变
然后你动画反正是差值的嘛
你看上去其实也挺像那么回事
这个方法呢实际上还是非常实用的
它在什么地方特别有用的
就是比如说在移动端的游戏中
其实很多移动端的游戏
到现在它的布料系统并不是真实的物理模拟
原因很简单
谁都跑不动
真实的物理server很费
那
诶我用这个简单的动画系统就可以做出
我们想要的医疗系统
其实也还是蛮好看的
那么第二种呢
刚才我们不是讲了ROG多吗
对不对
唉我把这个东西交给物理系统的这个结算
那这样的话我做几根就是register body的
这样的一个RAGDOLL的骨骼
然后呢这样的话才能实现什么呢
就当我这个角色走来走去
甚至我风给他吹一个力的时候
诶这个衣料好像也能飘了起来
就是这个叫什么呢
叫dynamic bone
动力学骨骼
实际上如果刚才讲的是那个那个那个
Kandemic bone
就是说ANIMANIMATED这个BB的话
那这个呢就是dynamic bone
动力学谱的方法做医疗
实际上呢这个在早期的PC游戏中
也是非常常见的
因为那个时候我们已经有了基础的物理
计算机了
但是呢我们又舍不得上
那么expensive的布料模拟
那我们用几根动力学给我放在这儿
那基本上也能实现整个衣服非常灵动的效果
但是呢今天的课程我们给大家讲的就是
稍微有意思一点
这也是现在游戏引擎发展的一个主流趋势
就是说我们用mesh base的方法去进行COSIMULATION
这样在这里面的话
你看见所有几乎所有动物的东西啊
它都是布料啊
这些布料的话呢
它实际上都是用网格的方法
就是一个顶点一个点的做物理学的解释动出来
那这里面大家看到颜色的不同的
但是我们会解释为什么每个颜色不同
那么其实这种mesh based cost simulation的话
第一步就是说
我得把我要做的这个物体的这个mesh找到
那这个物体的mesh呢真实渲染用的mesh啊
一般都会非常的细腻
非常的detail
你如果真的把这个几千个点
上万个点交给这个simulation
simulator去做simulation的话
大部分的物理引擎会当场死给你看
所以呢我们一般会对医疗
每个东西我们会做一个就是physical mass
就会相对来讲它的这个密度啊
会比原来大概小一个四五倍
是很正常
甚至是十倍以上
比如说你本来这个布料是4000个面的
但是呢我在做模拟的时候
可能是四五百个面
基本上效果就可以了
因为其实他也是有点像那个呃
就是vertex animation一样的
就是有些vertex其实可以通过那个
比如大家还记得我们前面讲过很多白
虽然这个那个把CENTRIC那个TEMPLATION吗
方法我就可以把一些洞
把他的一些运动
可以插值到那些其他的顶点里面去
当我们有了这样的一个一个一个
一个physical mesh的时候呢
我们一般会做一个权重的刷
大家想想看
很少有意料
真的是飘在空中的风吹得满地跑了
大部分的衣料是不是穿在人的身上面
对不对
那我这个衣服穿在这个角色上面
我们大家是不是不能接受
说比如一个披风对吧
走两步
这个披风布料一模拟它就飞了对吧
那衣服要废了
这肯定就有问题了
那怎么办呢
我们就会在每一个这个physics smash上面的话
画出它可以移动的范围
那一般来讲越靠近身体
越靠近固定固定点的地方呢
我们会把他的那个就是约束权重给它降下去
就是让他就是位置不要动
特别是比如说做披风的时候
沿着脖子的这一圈
我们会说你的flexibility
你或者是你的freedom就是零
你就在那别动了
但是越往下我会给你的空间就越大
但这里面有一个general practice
就是说我们在靠近身体的地方的话呢
会允许它动一动
但是呢也会不让它的幅度太大
为什么呢
因为幅度太大之后
他就特别容易和这个角色穿模
其实衣料穿模
我可以认为在目前的游戏引擎中
都很难解决的问题
但是现在越好的引擎啊
解决的越好
但这里面是有很多的挑战和问题在里面的
那么其实呢接下来的话呢作为artist来讲
它就比较简单了
它就可以设置很多
比如说我的意料的硬度啊
我的音意料的这个切向的
这种这种韧劲是多少呀
我能不能那个ANTIBAND啊
能不能阻碍这种这种这种折叠啊
这种能力对吧
那作为artist来讲
它就设置参数
但这件事情它就能够让我们生产出各种各样的
比如说丝绸质感的皮革质感的衣料
对吧
当然我们要结合我们的rendering
那一趴讲的PB2
我让他才是看的更正常
讲到这一趴
大家是不是觉得都很简单
都比较好懂对吧
但事实上我们作为引擎的开发者的话
我们的世界不是这样的
我们看到的世界是什么呢
首先衣料怎么模拟
这个时候我们会发现
就是说我们能用的工具居然是我们那个
这应该是初中物理的这个课程了吧
弹簧质点模型
我们只能把这个意料想象成无数的弹簧支点
就是我自己也有很深的感受
就是经常我们的artist会跟我们狂喷
说你的衣料做的不好啦
又穿了
怎么做都不像了
但是我们真的在写这些底层算法的人
我们就知道哥哥
你不知道我们有多痛苦啊
因为你今天看到这么漂亮的这些衣料的话
实际上是由无数个无数个质点和弹簧
模拟出来的
然后呢每一帧我都要做大量的结算
那先先讲它最简单的结算
就是一个弹簧上面的质点
它受到的力是怎么怎么来的
第一种力是什么呢
就是我们叫做行便利
就是说你拉开离开他的那个recipes
就是说他的那个就是这个这个零张力的那个位
置的时候
只根据你的位移
你无论是正向的负向
它就会得到一个相反方向的这个弹性力对吧
这个用胡克定理讲
就是你的位移乘上你的这个弹簧系数非常简单
另外一个还有什么呢
这个是大家很多时候会忽略掉的
就是说这个系统它是有一个叫dumpling的力
dumpling的力叫这个dumpling这个词是什么意思呢
就是衰减
其实我们在做真正的物理系统的时候
dumpling是非常重要的
那在这里面的话
你首先能看到的一个衰减是什么
我这个质点在移动的时候
我会受到空气的阻力对吧
实际上在这个医疗里面
这个空气阻力是非常重要的
为什么呢
因为我们虽然用的是弹簧质点模型
但是大家仔细想想
我们的衣服可是不是一个个的质点
它实际上每一个每一个质点和弹簧之间
表达的是一小块的面积啊
所以那一小块面积所受到的空气阻力
其实并不低的对吧
而且dumpling为什么很重要呢
这个但这一边是荡开一笔了
就是说无论我们去做什么样的一个物理模
模拟系统
如果你不去设置一个dumpling啊
它很可能因为有大量的数值迭代计算
包括公式上可能有些不准确的地方
包括浮点算运算的这个这样的一个一个误差
它的能量可能会爆炸
因为大家想象一下
我做过浮点运算
我一直做加法乘法除法
然后呢每次都溢出那么一点点
当你迭代个几千次
几万次的时候
最后的结果是什么
实际上你是不知道
而dumpling呢
它会让你的迭代稳定性提高特别多
所以这是一个绝对的黑科技
大家一定要用好
那我现在有了一个弹簧
一个支点
这个问题好解决
对吧好
那我接下来我要做个医疗
我怎么去构建我的弹簧质点模型呢
那实际上的话呢大家现在的做法是A
我去做很多的这种一把衣料
均匀地看成一个个的支点
然后呢我在它的横向纵向加上很多弹簧
你这样加行不行
其实也还可以
但是呢你会发现
这个时候当你去ban的这个弹簧的时候
它几乎是没有什么这个阻阻挠力的
所以我们一般有的时候会加他的
在cross里面会加个弹簧
实际上有的时候我们会专门加一些弹簧
横跨几个支点
就是比如说我要表
表现一种非常硬的这种布料的时候
我对他的单子的惩罚就会很大
那这个时候我会比如说横跨两三个支点
加一根弹簧
就是不让你折来折去
如果这个弹簧系统构建的就是过于稀疏的话
你做出的布料给人的感觉是什么呢
就是特别的吸软软的
都不太真实了
但是你说这东西对不对呢
我个人觉得对于某些某些布料举个例子啊
比如说像丝绸这种感觉还是挺挺有感觉的
所以其实我认为就是这个做医疗的
这个这个力学模型啊
很多时候它就是一个经验经验
一个hack
你自己构建一个模型
那么在这个里面的好像是行业用的比较多的
那好我们完整的讲一下
说诶
这里面
当我把我的一个质点放到一个完整的布料里面
我们会受到哪些力呢
哎这个时候就比较复杂了
就是对于中间的那个红色的点来讲
我们会收到哪些礼
第一个大家很容易忘记的
我们是生活在地球上的
地球上有什么有重力
对其实在做所有的衣料模拟的时候
你千万不要忘了重力
为什么呢
因为你如果没有重力的话
这个衣料飘起来之后
它就永远飞掉了
它不会落下来的对吧
必须要重力把所有人就落下来
那么第二个是什么呢
就是风为什么风是单独的呢
因为大家想想看啊
当我穿着这个这个披风
我这个像风一样的男子这样跑起来对吧
飞起来从悬崖上跳下来
那实际上你包括其他风了吧
那个时候这个风啊
它是一个consistent apply到你身上的一个力
这个风力其实非常的重要
所以呢这也是让我们大部分游戏
如果没有风力的话
那个斗篷都是耷拉下来的
虽然角色动的时候动两下
但是你只要一停
它就耷拉下来
只有有风的时候
才让这个角色看上去就那么的有个性对吧
其实如果大家玩一些二次元游戏的时候
你就知道那个角色的披风
永远是和他的身体形成一个完美的一个家教
让你觉得这个角色看上去
总是那么的膨胀和有立体感
也是这个道理
那么好
接下来呢就是我刚才提到的就是空气阻力对吧
这个空气阻力呢取决于你当前的速度
所以刚才这个就是一般来讲
我们用个最简单的公式
就是它跟速度成一个线性比值
其实这个是这个东西
基本是啊
怎么说呢
其实如果严格的讲的话
它应该是速度的平方
但是我们这边不要去纠结这个细节了
在低速情况下
我就用线性简单的模拟一下
而接下来就是说你周边所有的弹簧
从各个方向对你施展的力
注意弹簧给你施展
你是有两种的
一个是胡克定理决定的弹力
对不对
还有一个是什么
大家很容易忽忽略了
叫dumpling
就是说弹簧它也不是一直能动的
就是如果你只有虎颗粒的话
大家想想看这个弹簧会怎么样
它会永远的做简谐振动对吧
如果你现在做过医疗模拟的话
你只要扰动它一个顶点一下
如果按照这个理论模型的话
他会不会永远的来回答
哒哒哒哒哒
这样动
对不对
这是你想要的结果吗
不是大家想要的结果
所以我们一定要加个dumpling
就是弹簧
你虽然给了他一个初始的输出之后
它动了动了动了
因为内部的摩擦力啊
就是把你的机械能变成热能之后
哎它就能停得下来
所以这是一个真正的当我们做医疗的时候
我们看到的这个物理世界的模型好
那我们怎么去积分它
我有了这个模型之后
其实这里面的每一每式子的每一项
并不那么难算
那这里面的话呢
我们要给大家讲一个非常有意思的积分
叫word的积分
它它的积分的巧妙的地方是什么呢
就是如果这里面我们用到了
比如说你在空间上的位置对吧
还取决于你的速度
那么位置和速度之间又是一个相互反向
积分的这个关系其实是有点小复杂的
但我们真正的医疗模拟的时候
我记得我们在上节课我们讲过
叫半隐式欧拉积分
我也跟大家分析过
就是说半影视欧拉积分的话呢
它既具有很方便的计算
它与影视欧拉积分其实算起来更方便
而且呢他更加的收敛
但是的话呢后面的数学大牛就是VLAD
他提出了一个方法
就是说诶既然半影是很好的话
那我可以把你的这个积分呢变成只跟速度有关
而且呢更加的稳顶
我这边重点给大家讲一下这个积分的思想啊
就是首先大家想想办饮食积分是什么概念
就是说我首先我的在德尔塔T时间之后
我的速度是不是有我当前的速度
再加上一个我的加速度乘上一个时间对吧
那么我新的位移就是X的T加德尔塔T的时候
是不是你当前的位置加上V的
就是德尔塔T后的速度
就是未来的这个速度乘上了德尔塔T
对不对
这里面的话呢
它就有一个很有趣的一个observation
是这样的
就是你的速度
比如说你当前的速度是什么
是由什么决定
实际上是你当前的位置
应该有你上一个德尔塔T时间的位置
加上的你当前的速度乘上个德尔塔T
为什么呢
因为你当前的速度也是由你上一帧半音时
而来的
这个这个方法是很巧妙的
这个SERVATION
那这样的话呢
你当你把这个公式放到一起去整理的时候啊
你就会发现
其实VT你可以用这个上一帧的位置
和德尔塔T的关系就能表达出来
所以他把这两个式子一整理
你就会发现啊
就是他最后得出的结论就是XT加德尔塔T呢
它是等于是个指东西
叫做两倍的XT
就是当前的这个位置减下去上一帧的位置
然后再乘上你的AAHA值
有什么唯一动决定就是你的受的力决定
对不对
再乘上一个德尔塔T的平方
就是时间的平方
那么这个公式它为什么很巧妙的
大家会觉得这不是数学上是等价的吗
你有什么好说的
但是大家仔细想想
当我们在做这个就是模拟的时候
我们每一帧每一个tick tick tick
我模拟的最准确的是什么
是你的位置
其实你的速度是用我的位置反推过来的
而且呢我有当前帧的位置
其实我在cash一下上一帧的位置也不难对吧
那我下一帧的位置的话呢
他就把这个事情简化成了
叫做上一帧的位置和这一帧的位置
再加上我受到的力
我用这个简单的方程
我就能算出来你的这个下一站的位置在哪里
我指那么这个积分
你在数学上看上去是等价的对吧
但实际上它是一个非常好的一个平衡
为什么呢
因为如果你老是用未
就是那个就是用那个速度去算速度
在某一个瞬间的时候
可能会变得非常大或者是不稳定
一旦你某些速度不稳定之后
你这个积分本身就会变得这个integration
就会变得非常的不稳定
而VT的话呢
它就非常巧妙的把这种不稳定的
因此给它去掉了
而且word积分实际上也是更快的
所以在我们的布料模拟之后的话呢
我们很多时候用VERTT积分
这个来取代半隐式欧拉积分
大大大家注意一个细节
就是说实际上从思想上是和半隐式的欧拉积分
是等价的
那这一趴的数学呢实际上大家后面仔细看
其实并不是特别的难理解
而且我个人觉得是蛮巧妙的一个方法好
那么其实呢我在这一盘还不展开
但是后面我给大家提一下
其实布料模拟啊
现在最主流的方法实际上是PPT
就是position based dynamics
就是基于位置的动力学模拟
它的好处是什么呢
就是它的简单的思想
我在这边只提一句
就是说如果刚才我教我教给大家的方法
它是一个很标准的一个经典力学的方法
就是牛顿力学的方法
就是说根据约束
我可以算出它的力
根据力我算出它的速度
根据它的速我算出它的位移对吧
这个是一个非常合理的一个因果关系
但是呢有一套另外一套的数学
就是我们以前讲的拉格朗日数学
他把所有的力学关系描述成了一堆数学的
叫约束
他认为所有的力学过程
必须要符合我的数学约束
我是直接用constrain约束
直接解除你的位置
而我不再去关心你的速度
这个非常的巧妙
那么这种解法它的好处是什么呢
就是它能处理一些非常复杂的情况
同时呢它这个server本身是非常的稳定的
就其实复不复杂呢
我觉得仁者见仁智者见智
但是他的server第一个是会比较快
第二个呢它能够在一些非常复杂的
非常的就是说精度敏感的情况
讲解的非常的稳定
像这里面这一条几万个面的龙
我用一块布料从头上划过去
其实这个case大家如果真的学过物理模拟的话
就知道这个case非常的难
其实到现在这个这个视频我拿过来的话
我一直在跟课程组的小伙伴上在讨论
说这个demo它到底是real time还是not real time
其实我们知道就算不是real time的话
这个demo也是非常复杂
很难写的好
所以的话呢pd呢我在后面会单独去讲
但是大家知道就是说在现代的游戏引擎啊
引擎中
越来越多的布料模拟
使用的其实不是刚才那个简单的弹簧支顶
我他用的还是弹簧质点模型
但是呢不再是用简单的速度加速度方法去解
而是用PPT的思想去解好
关于布料这一趴呢
我们算法server讲到这儿
但是布料里面一个特别特别恶心的东西
是什么呢
叫自穿插SOLICATION对吧
像这边的
像我们的那个左边的这个布料
大家看
如果我们把SELFICATION关掉之后
它的布料之间就会互相穿插
然后那么薄的东西一穿插之后
你基本上没法看
就这里面的例子
就是它两面用了两个不同的颜色嘛
就算两边的颜色一样
比如说里面的衣服和外面的衣服花纹不一样
当它动起来的时候
两个布料在在一起是会经常打架的
特别在取色身上哦
我们今天课程组还在商量
就大家都说这个布料的CLICHEN
这个其实挺讲解的
我说是
而且现在是越来越重要
因为我们现在在表达一个角色的时候
他的衣服都要穿好几层
那每一层布料都在做自我的模拟
刚才大家看了已经觉得有点高能了
对不对
但是大家想想看
当我这么多层布料在一起模拟的时候
怎么办对吧
那万一穿插了
比如说一个这个这个这个比如说一个小的
这个里面的T恤甲是蓝色的
外面罩了一件外套
比如说是白色的
好那个蓝色的外那个T恤老是穿透出来
出现在白色的外套上面
大家一看哇
这个游戏很渣渣
很这个质量不行
其实这就是我们真实的在做游戏引擎
特别是做物理引擎的时候
我们所面临的一个巨大的一个挑战
那这里面的话呢我就给大家简单的去点一下
现在的一些常用的方法
比如说最土的方法怎么样
我把布料的这个这个物理模拟模型把它加厚
就意思意思就是说你虽然是穿过去了
但是呢你只要穿的不够深
我还是不让你去透出来对吧
但这个就很土了
还有呢
就是说我把布料的物理仿真的步伐变得更细
拆成很多subs step
这样的话当我就能够保证在我server去解的时候呢
我不会过深的穿透过你的这个布料
这个也是一个
就是我们认为
用计算复杂度来换这个稳定性的问题
那么还有一种方法呢
就是我们叫做maximum velocity
就刚才我提到
就是说其实真正在布料模拟的时候
有的时候速度这一项它其实是不稳定的
所以呢很多时候的穿插
就是说你就是大家如果真的解那个物理server
你会发现一个问题是
当一个东西它穿过去之后
他不除非你专门处理它
否则是弹不回来的
他就真的穿过去了
因为他会认为那个状态又是一个物理的稳定态
大家仔细想想
就是说你把一个一个一个缸
一个缸体击穿到另一个缸体
是不是
击穿之后他如果能穿得了
它在里面停下来
其实也是个稳定的状态
对不对
它也符合我们的物理学的约束
那这个时候呢他就设置了一个maximum speed
就保证在每个subs step上的话
你不会把它穿得过深
这样你还能弹回来
那么一个更精更精确的做法呢
他就加一个立场
这个立场呢它一般会设置在布布布料的里面
就是说当你穿过去之后
那个立场它能检测出来那个立场全是负向立场
他就把你的东西往回往往回顶
就是我在讲图形学的时候
讲过一个叫sdf sin distance field对吧
其实它就相当于在布料里面建了一层
这个负向的sign sdf的这个distance field
当我有一个模拟simulation
有一块布料它穿到我的里面去之后
我这个SDF就起作用了
就会给你产生一个反向的impulse管理
在提听出来
反正anyway
这里面的话
其实真正的实施和骇客其实是非常非常多的
那为什么这里面我给大家点一下呢
我只是想让大家知道
就是说其实classsimulation self collision detection的话呢
实际上是一个非常重要的一个model
也是很重要的一个课题
其实不止布料自己之间了
还包括就是布料和缸体之间
因为我们在角色
比如特别是角色在动的时候啊
我们的物理的这个body
实际上是比真实的角色要要简单的对吧
它并不完全重合
但是呢你的布料一旦跟这个这个
比如说你的大腿表达
用SELENDER去碰撞的时候
它会碰撞出一个不正确的一个结果
那么如果我的这个钢铁在某个角度的话呢
它占用的体积是比真实的
我的这个体积要小的话
就会出现叫做我的物理系统
认为我已经把你顶出去了
但是呢诶你当我去渲染的时候
我那个地方的皮肤又露出来了
这个时候就很尴尬
就所以大家以前在看很多的早期游戏的时候
这种布料模拟的话
很容易出过你单身的大部分早期游戏的时候
是不会用真实的物理去进行布料模拟
他很多时候就像我刚才讲了一个动画的方法
用这个其他的方法来实现
所以呢还好
所以这也是在未来
大家实现这种高品质游戏的时候
其实是也是一个必须要解决的一个问题
其实实话实说
我到现在也没认为我知道一个很好的解
我这个还是一个非常前沿的
大家都在研究的一个领域
那么好
讲完这么难的数学的布料
接下来讲一个比较有意思的系统
就是这个破坏系统的
破坏系统在我们的游戏引擎中是由来已久了
而且我觉得这也是属于大家特别喜闻乐见的一
个东西对吧
就是从超级马里奥时代
我觉得最大的乐趣就是把人家强撞的一塌糊涂
你就觉得哇
我这个我感觉我是在创造这个世界的玩法
那么其实呢就是破坏系统呢
对于现代游戏引擎来讲是非常重要的
因为它实际上它不仅是一种视觉表现
更到现在已经越来越变成一种
可以跟play的东西了
比如像我们大名鼎鼎的彩六对吧
那你在墙上打洞
在什么地方打洞
用什么枪打洞
这可就是你最核心的一个战术了
所以实际上我个人
就像上次我记得我在讲那个graphics的时候
我讲过一个就是walker base的这个turn的表达
我就想为什么我会对那个东西个人很感兴趣
因为我一直在幻想
就是有一个游戏
我能够自由的去挖战壕
自由的去挖地道
自由的去拆掉别人墙
构筑各种我想要的公式
那样的游戏是我觉得那是游戏的本身
所以我认为destruction的这个系统的话
实际上就是给用户了这样的一种自由
那么好
那么destruction怎么实现的呢
其实他想起来也并不简单
就是并不复杂
就是说当我给你一个没有被破坏的物体的时候
其实啊你用一种hierarchy的方法
你可以把这个物体分成一节一节一节的碎片
那么这一节的碎片的话呢
我们一般会用HT的方法把它组织起来
这样会让你的这个破坏
这个碎片看上去更有结构感
其实我们看见就是说当我打一个东西的时候
他不是你打在他不同的地方
它不会一下子全部碎掉了对吧
你会感觉有些地方A打掉了一大片
有的地方就掉了一点点
那这个碎片的话呢
我是用自动生成的方法把它生生成出来
形成一个树状的结构
当我有了这样的一个树状结构之后呢
我接下来建立一个什么呢
它它的连接关系
就是你可以理解成
就是碎片A和碎片B之间的话
它的连接到底有多牢固对吧
这个地方我就形成了很多的H
大家想想这里面的一个DEFGH
这些碎片的话
实际上它们就会有相应的连接线
这也是一个游戏引擎里面一个标准的一个课件
告诉你说你怎么去做一个可以破坏的物体
那么每一个connection
实际上它都有一个就是它的权重叫value
这个value就表示它能够承受的多大的冲击
或者多大的这个力
那这个这个数值呢其实表达的是什么呢
就是它的这个我们叫做印度
那么这个印度怎么起作用呢
很简单
当我来了一个东西撞我的时候
大家还记得我们在物理引擎里面讲的是什么
是一个冲量对吧
Impulse
那么这个印度呢就会说
OK你冲量和我的impulse之间算出了一个值
就是你的冲量和我的硬度之间形成一个值
这个值就是你对我是真实形成的一个damage
当你这个damage
这个值超过我一开始设定的那个阈值的话
那我这个东西就断了就对吧
他是这么一个简单段
但这里面其实有非常多的问题的
因为我个人虽然说
这也是游戏引擎里面经常的一个时间
但我一直在思考的一个问题
就是说首先impulse是有量纲的对吧
但印度这个量纲的话呢
和我们真实在物理学上的量纲是不太一致的
大家知道物理学的印度是有什么十级对吧
大家记得金刚石石
对不对
然后他讲的那个硬度指的是两个东西摁在一起
我多大了
尽力下去之后
它不炸掉和你这种在冲击力之下
他不会去炸掉这个硬度
我个人认为他在物理学上是有不一样的表达了
因为物理学上你真的一个东西能打断的话
还有什么
除了印度还有什么
还有它的韧度
就是它的任力
包括就是说他之所以产生那个折断效应
实际上是在那个点上产生的应力
超过了我的阈值
但是呢当这个当这个artist
我让他去标识这里面的23是100的时候
实际上artist是完全没有概念的
他就会觉得哦
那我标个300吧
标个100吧
好像就像那么回事
但实际上它的物理学意义鬼才知道
没人知道对吧
然后呢我们还假模假样的搞了个这么个公式
就是说当我有一个球打中一个点的时候
哎我们会把它所有的这个damage
以一个一个同心圆的方法分散出去
这个这个公式看上去特别高大上
实际上非常的简单
就是我装的这个点在一个相对小的范围里面
所有人受到的damage都是一样的
就是你的impulse都是一样的
然后呢当这个就是这个点的话呢
就是足够的
就是扩散的时候
他逐渐就从这个百分之百的这个冲击
到0%的冲击
然后做个做个差值
但是特别honest
我觉得这全是hack
就是说我不认为
今天我们在做这个destruction系统的时候
这个问题有个很好的讲解
因为我今天跟我们课程组合在一起
举个例子
比如说我们我很难跟artist讲
就说你拿一个步枪子弹
你去打一颗子弹
大家知道一个步枪子弹所射出去的这个冲
这个冲力啊是非常大的
可以达到几千焦耳的这样的一个能量对吧
但是的话呢我们比如说啊我们一个人
他用很大的力气去撞一个墙
你所产生的冲量大概也就几十焦耳对吧
但是你如果我真的做一个东西的时候
我artist说诶这个这一面墙我用子弹一打
这个墙就掉掉了对吧
但是呢我用人撞这个墙总是撞不开
其实有的时候你会觉得有一点奇怪
所以这个呢也是我认为就是说只是在引擎中
大家会这么做
但其实我相信在未来一个更加的物理追问的
这样一个游戏世界里面的话呢
我相信他有一些更好的一个表达
那这里面的话呢就是说当我这样的一个物体
我已经把他的这个CHK
就是这种destruction的唱K分好了之后呢
我就会把它放在这个世界里面
一般我们会做这个supporting graph
就是说他会这个东西会挂在某个地方
比如他一个窗子就挂在窗子frame里面对吧
他如果是在墙上的一个突出部
那就挂在墙上了
这样的好处就是说当他产生了这种破坏的时候
它实际上只会对那个区域会产生一个破坏效果
而不会把整个这个就是东西给破坏掉
那么这个东西唱K到底怎么生成的
这个图好像有点问题
实际上那个我们这个图是要展示的
就是你在那个角受了力之后
他就那一那一侧掉下来了
但我相信同学们学到这一趴的时候
应该都已经知道自己怎么会想
因为我们前面讲的东西比这个要复杂得多
这个地方是非常的直觉
那怎么样的自动生成唱歌呢
因为你不能老是让人家美术去帮你
把这个东西分割好吧
但其实有的时候我们还真的让美术分割
因为美术分割有时候它会形成我们想要的结果
那这里面最常用的算法就是大名鼎鼎的vi算法
我相信上次我们上节课
我们在讲那个语音的时候
讲noise生成的
好像就提到过大名鼎鼎的模拟算法
它简单来讲就是你在空间上随机撒一些种子
然后呢
你把这个空间分割成一个到每一个种子的距离
都对等的这个边界
这个东西在生物学上是很有用的
其实你们小时候如果看过那个生物课
你们那个细胞你看到那个细胞核对吧
特别是植物细胞
细胞和细胞壁形成的那个划分
就是一个标准的warning划分
哎我这个很有意思
我其实整个细胞的生长
它是非常符合这个数学规律的
那么就是我现在给你一个形体的时候
比如说一个2D的mesh
实际上我就给他
我算他一个绑定
然后呢我就随机的产生一些种子点
然后呢形成的纹理划分之后诶
我就能形成这样的一个碎片
大家看看这个碎片看上去是不是就很很自然
很真实
所以其实数学是非常简单的
那么如果你是个3D
实际上我也是用这个类似的算法
但是呢我RONI对空间形成划分之后呢
我还得用一个就是那个DERISE的算法
把它就是空间进行三角化
这个DRUNNING算法化简化三角化呢稍微有点复杂
但其实也不难
大家如果想查就可以查得到它
简单来讲就是我可以把空间划分成无数个
就TJHEER
就是说这个就是四面体
就四面体的话完成一个对空间的划分
因为你本身的形体是各种各样的
所以说你用这些台式
黑色角去划分的空间的时候
你会得到一些看上去非常有意思的这些碎片
就像这个雕像一样的对吧
你给他算出一个绑定
你
然后呢用那个那个那个DCT的那个DERIA的算法
把它分成这个四边形的
就是四面体的空间
提速的时候
再配合上它本来的形状
就看上去就很很真实
很自然
但是to be honest这个东西看上去还是比较粗糙
但这里面有一个非常有意思的一个细节
这也是我特别想让大家注意到的
就是当一个形体
比如说我们建一个模的时候
我给它形成一个贴图对吧
那这个贴图看上去就很好看
但是当我把这个花瓶打碎的时候
你会发现最难的一件事情啊
实际上我要生成一个就是volin texture
就是说因为比如说一棵树啊
树可能不大
树不太容易打碎啊
比如说一个大理石
你把它打碎的时候
你在断痕处看到的是很多大理石的花纹
对不对
那个花纹实际上是有一个分布的
那个切口处的纹理啊
其实生成是比较复杂的
而这种东西的话呢
一般当我们做真的做3D破碎的时候
特别是这种大体量的3D破碎
比如说一个雕像的破碎对吧
比如说一个砖墙的破碎的时候
我们就会要处理这个断口处的纹理生成的问题
那这里面一般有两个流派了
一个流派
就是说哎我干脆就是有一套procedure的方法
生成3D的涡轮texture
你这样用的时候就直接去我的VOLTEXTURE的事
但是大家知道3D的texture
无论从生成到采样都很复杂对吧
还有一种方法的话呢
就是我离线把这些texture uv都给你算好
所以一旦你碎了之后
哎我就把你的渲染切过去
所以这个东西其实蛮复杂的
而且它在一瞬间啊
那个破坏的一瞬间
它就要为每一个碎片生成一个它的rigid body
因为碎片之间最复杂的是什么
他们彼此之间还要碰撞
所以destruction啊
在很多游戏中是一个非常expensive的一个东西
比如说在我们的很多游戏实践中啊
就这些DEBRICK就是我打出来的这些碎片
一般来讲不不要不要让他去参加物理逻呃
游戏逻辑的结算
其实在我们在座很多游戏的时候
很多人都说我特别希望有一炮把那个墙给轰塌
然后墙掉下来的石头把这个角色给砸死
对这件事情我们都觉得很好玩
但实际上你会发现除了单机游戏之外
大部分的网游他都不敢这么做
为什么呢
因为我们讲过那个deterministic对吧
同一个物理事件在不同的玩家的终端上
它模拟出来的结果都是不一样的
那如果不一样的话
他那个轨迹砸下来的弹道
包括角色的位置同步都不一样
所以很很可能在你的世界里面
你认为那个石头把一个人砸死了
但是呢在另外一个时间点
他看起来完全没有砸到
所以呢这也是就是destruction系统
它在未来一个非常大的一个挑战
当然我们也知道有些物理引擎也在client
他说他能解决这个问题
那么这个destruction的这个这个CHK生成啊
实际上是有很多的更多的细节了
比如说在一些比较好的引擎里面
这里面我举了的例子
就是
实际上你可以指定说我生成的这个这个
这个fracture的这个pattern是什么
比如说它更均匀地碎掉
还是说它更结构化一点
就是有大大小小
还有可能比如像玻璃这种
它是沿着一个方向快速的就是极化掉
那这个的话呢就会给我们的artist更大的空间
去表达他要表达的世界
那么所以呢其实我们在整个物理引擎来讲的话
destruction是一个很重要的环节
一般来讲的话
我们是把它放在collision之后
就是因为很多的destruction事件
都是在clean社会发生的
比如说一个东西掉下来了
或者说我射出去了一个子弹
但是这个这个可能更像是SQUIRY了对吧
或者我砸出去的一个一个一个球
这个球最后撞到一个东西
或者我我一个一个character
他撞到一个东西之后
哎我们会发生这种就是说那个destruction的事件
然后我们去update它所有的这个这个碎片
其实更复杂的情况是什么
就是我一个东西它已经碎了诶
我我害怕跟碎片再进行一些互动
实际上的话呢
这个就是物理引擎写下来就很麻烦
但是确实要写
那么其实的话呢
就是在真实的物理引擎和游戏引擎里面的
distraction啊
我们一般会加很多的回调事件
它要配合相应的就是这种生效或者是效果
因为你的这个破坏
一旦没有了这些生效和party系统的话
你会觉得它的真实感有很多的问题
简单来讲
比如说我一个破坏生成了一些比较大的碎片
当这些碎片落到地上的时候
你是不是应该看到一些小小的烟尘
你还应该听到一些声音对吧
其实在我们在写物理引擎做物理结算的时候
实际上每一个碎片它变成一个raid body的时候
当它和环境发生这种contact的时候
你都要给你的上层的用户提供一些回调的函数
让他决定说我是否要播放一个特效
我是否要播放一个生效
否则的话你那个场景看上去再酷
它实际上也是很塑料
所以大家到这一趴的话呢
我希望让同学们能感受到
就是说在做一个真实的游戏的这个物理引擎
它其实啊复杂度还是非常高
因为人对这种fidelity就是这种真实性的东西啊
它的PROCEPTION
特别是物理感的东西是非常非常敏锐的好
那么其实呢就是destruction呢
我觉得最大的问题
刚才我已经反复点到这件事情
就是说大家会觉得游戏中非常酷的一个东西
但实际上在现代游戏中呢
我们一般都会非常谨慎的使用
因为一旦参与破坏的东西多少
它生成的碎片可能是成千上万
而且接下去以这个例子
你看这个是我们实时录下来的
这是我们在那个joint引擎里面做的模拟
这个案例里面的话
你会发现它的速度就很慢
为什么它碎成了这个上几百块
上千块的碎片的时候
他每个碎片都在高速的互相碰撞
互相结算
这样你才能看到这种碎片逐渐散开的效果
否则的话这些碎片散开了之后全叠到一起去了
但是你看到这么很自然的翻转
散开的这个效果的话
在物理解上里面其实是非常非常的复杂的
这就是我认为就是大家很多时候在讲
我们的游戏引擎嘛
在我看来的话
就是如果我们认为真实的世界是一个大的
一个simulation
就是上帝写的一个模拟器的话
那我们人类写的模拟器在它面前
那简直就是小巫见大巫啊
简直都这个不知道差到哪里去了
所以说我们未来的游戏引擎
它其实对算力的需求是非常巨大的
就比今天的算力再大两个三个数量级
我们都会消耗得掉
因为我们会有很多的细节需要表达
就刚才我讲的那个布料对吧
包括像头发系统
像这个物理的破坏系统
实际上你想做得好的话
它对算力的需求非常的高
另外一个就是说它的系统对
这个就是计算的复杂
就是那个算法的复杂度实际上也会高很多很多
今天我们做了很多的模拟
都是做了大量的简化
所以呢这一点的话
当当当我们讲的DISCORTION这1part的时候
希望同学们建立这样一个基础的概念
好接下来给大家讲一个这个destruction的话呢
提一下就比较常见的应用啊
比如说像PHX里面最著名的那个apex这个系统
就是一个最著名的一个destruction
一个系统
这个早年也是很惊艳的一个系统
那现在的话呢它把它升级到了blast了
然后呢这个NVD啊
他现在想搞那个ominous
就开始偷偷摸摸的把他的开源协议也换掉了
而且呢那个physics也也不再去维护和更新了
对吧
你懂的
这个这个这个黄教主总是那么的那个英明神武
然后呢
把我们这个这个这个老百姓的快乐
全部给切断掉了
那么当然了
还有很著名的
比如像那个havoc引擎
当年也是以破坏文明的
那havoc的话呢
自从被应该是被微软收购之后吧
就是非常非常的贵对吧
而且维护起来好像也没有那么积极了
那么当然了
现在还有这个就是unreal引擎
虚幻引擎的这个KOS的这个物理引擎
那么这个呢号称是完全用XPPT的算法
待会我给大家解释什么XPPT
然后呢号称是性能最强的这样的一个物理引擎
但是呢就是在目前的行业工业界那么好
就在我们的游戏行业里面
大家实战中用的还不多
所以呢这个东西还有待观察
看它的真实的效果对
接下来给大家讲了这一趴呢
就我个人是最喜欢的一趴是什么
是vehicle载具系统
我个人为什么那么喜欢呢
因为从我开始会写游戏引擎的时候
就可以
或者说从我动了念头想去写游戏的时候
我就自己想写一个这样的一个赛车游戏
我觉得这个小车坐起来真的很可爱
我做各种地形
我自己会对着他津津有味的玩个一晚上
完全没有问题对吧
我所以所以就是我一直在想说
一辆小车是怎么做的
那今天呢我就给大家做个简单的这个科普
就是说在游戏引擎里面
因为这也是属于游戏引擎的一个服务
就是我们一般来讲vehicle是physics engine
PC通过游戏引擎开放给开发者的一个标准接口
那么好
我们要知道这个一个vehicle怎么做的
其实vehicle啊他的表达有很多变种
比如说这个我们中国大名鼎鼎的
什么叫这个这个什么什么飞车对吧
各种各样的飞车
有各种很炫酷的技术
很多人认为我是这个什么什么飞车的漂移大神
对不对
那么这个道非常真实的
比如说像FA像need for speed
Need to be honest
我个人觉得need of speed
不是一个以写实著称的游戏
那个那个赛车游戏啊
我一直认为FA是比较写实的
还有一个忘了叫什么了
反正这个东西是非常拉仇恨的一场讨论
就是每一个每个人都有自己
最爱的一个赛车游戏
让彼此就互相看不上对方对吧
但anyway
就是说有一大批的这个赛车游戏的话呢
其实是非常非常做的
非常非常真实的
特别像那个dirt对吧
就是那个以拉力赛
越野赛为为著称的这样一个赛车的游戏
那我们怎么在游戏世界里面表达一个就是赛车
一辆车呢
其实非常的简单
但是我这边讲的是最简单的模型啊
OK我们给他一个这样的一个一个一个
一个一个一个缸体放在上面
那下面呢我放两个轮子
两个轮子是什么呢
其实就是弹簧对吧
但是这个轮子和地面是有contact
那这个缸体在动的时候
这个地面一直在变
那个缸体一直在动
它就会不停的压缩和和拉伸
那个弹簧是什么
就是我们叫做汽车的悬挂系统
如果你们回头看看你们家的车啊
你会发现每辆车你仔细看它的轮
轮子的轴承和那个车架连接的地方
都有那种一圈圈的那个弹簧
那就是全悬挂系统
有的车更牛逼的
我记得好像什么空气悬挂
还有什么什么什么液压悬挂
我就不知道了
反正特别的专业啊
但anyway
他其实你可以把它理解成一个弹簧
那好这样的话这个车如果能动的话
它是不是就是已经能模拟一个车
上下上下翻翻滚的这个样子了
那这个时候其实车是怎么能动起来的呢
首先它有一个驱动力对吧
Traction false
驱动力从什么地方来
是由engine来对吧
engine其实会输出一个东西
什么东西呢叫做扭矩
那么大家如果在那个
就是你们如果喜欢买那种越野车的时候
买这种大马力的车的时候
比如说著名的美式肌肉车直线加速之王的话
它实际上那个车最高速度并不高
但是它的扭矩脱口特别大
扭矩大就表示他的那个加速大
但是这个汽车的扭矩啊实际上是很复杂的
如果真实的大家做真实的赛车游戏啊
我们会写一个什么呢
叫发动机转速
油门和它的扭矩之间的关系
那是一条很奇怪的一个曲线
但没关系
这个交给这个小引擎工程师去给我输出来
我也不管这个参数
我就读进来了对吧
所以大家如果玩赛车游戏的时候
你们会发现就是不同的赛车
你的这个油门的感觉对吧
和加速感觉是完全不一样的
包括你买真实的车也是在这边有区别
那么好
这个扭矩啊
它要经过在传统的汽油车要通过什么呢
一个叫档位器
就是变速箱对吧
shift就是我换挡
这变速箱还有什么呢
还有一个差速器
把这个扭矩给差分到你的各个轮子里面
差速器这个概念比较高端
其实我说实话不是所有的车都有差速器
但是我据说现在所有的新新车都是有差速器的
差速器
我知道以前的理解是什么
就是越野赛车的时候
他的那个每个轮子它的力量分配是不一样的
比如说我有一只轮子悬空了
有一只轮子抓到地面了
他就差数据会更多的那个talk扭扭矩
移到它这一侧
能抓到地面的轮子上
帮助这个车车脱困
但我不知道这东西已经成了标配了
这样就转化成你真实的扭曲
而这个真实的扭矩的话呢
它实际上和你的这个这个这个地面上的
这个旋转
这个这个轴
这个这个就是这个半径输出去之后
那么我就可以算出一个什么东西
算出你在地面上产生的一个真实的
向前的这个力
这个力就是我汽车往前的这个驱动力
所以这就是汽车和地面啊
就往前动了一个技术点
就是说白了它是一个静摩擦力
它不是个不是个叫
我记得我们以前学过滑动摩擦力和静摩擦对吧
其实轮胎只要不打滑
只要你不弯漂移的话
它和地面的摩擦关系是个静摩擦关系
就是它始终是在那个点上形成一个链接的好
那这个车呢实际上还有一个力是什么呢
是悬挂
悬挂的一个力呢
其实比较简单
就是说它有一个REPLES
这个车就放在这儿
但是车在跑的过程中动
对不对
如果你这个轮胎放长了
这个车就会往下压
试图往下压
你这个车呢如果比如说从一个坡下来之后
车身往下惯性气候
他就试图把你车往上顶对吧
因为你有四个轮子
四个悬挂
所以呢这个车你会出现这种
左摇右晃的这种现象
但是如果做的好
调校的好
你这个车本身就比较稳
所以呢它有一个suspension
就是悬挂的这个动力好
还有什么呢
就是轮胎力
轮胎力其实比大家想象的比较复杂
其实汽车在移动的时候
它为什么可以转向
它有两个轮胎里
一个轮胎里呢是沿着它的
这个就是镜像的这个摩擦力
就long titude的摩擦力
这个实际上你可以理解成
就是说他如果只是前轮的导向轮的话
它就是一个单纯的沿着前轮的这个
镜像的这样的一个力
这个力的话呢就是你的阻力而已
但是如果是驱动轮的话
它实际上要加上一个你往前推的这个driver
这个力对吧
它形成这样的一个往前进的这个TXT的这个力
那么关键的一个力是什么呢
就是它的切下面
因为当我们的轮胎打了一个方向之后
你移动方向是A
但是呢你的轮胎往这样去走了之后
它会产生一个切向力
这个切向力的话呢实际上是一个滑动摩擦力
而这个滑动摩擦力呢
实际上就是我们汽车一个很重要的一个导向力
那么这个力呢它的大小既受制于我的摩擦系数
其实也受制于我的重心
因为你想大家想想看
我的重心越靠前的话
我那边的压力是不是越大
重心越后
那边压力就越小
所以这个也会影响到我的整个力的分分布
所以其实如果我们解解一个车的导向方程的话
你会发现你要把这两个力分开算
你才能算出来这个车啊
有多大的力气往一边去转
而且你会发现为什么这个轮胎打了之后
它会有的时候会出现打滑
其实也是这个道理
因为它每一个摩擦力都有上限好
这是一个最最简单的一个汽车模型
To be honest
但是呢这已经不妨碍我做一个非常简单的
我自己自娱自乐的一个汽车模特汽车游戏了
当然你想做FA
你想做need speed
这个还太远了
但是我做一个简单的小飞车游戏
我觉得还是可以的好
这个时候的话呢一个很重要的概念就是重心
重心实际上是那个set up max的话呢
它实际上是对车的驾驶的体感影响特别大
但其实它的计算方法也非常简单
就是你你前后两个支点对吧
前前轮组
后轮组在中间的那个那个重量的那个中心点
就在他们中间找一个点
这个这个点的话
其实很多时候也是你车最关键的一个属性
大家知道对车的重心啊
特别是小车影响最大的东西是什么呢
至少在汽油车时代影响最大的是那个发动机
因为汽油车有发动机的密度是最大的
一个大铁坨子
放到前面重心就靠前了
放到后面重心就靠后了对吧
那么这也是那个就是啊到这里面有个细节
就是如果你要做那个轿车的话
其实在早年的很多轿车都是前轮既当导向轮
又当驱动轮的
所以那个就是前驱车的这个啊
待会我也讲了
就是说前驱车的转向力就会比较差
OK好
那么其实重心的话呢
实际上对车子的影响是蛮大的
就是说一般来讲你的重心如果太靠前的话
当你去做这个车子飞升的时候
它就很容易一头栽下去
这个车子就不太稳定
如果重心偏后的话呢
这个车呢它会在飞跃的时候相对稳定
大家如果玩过拉力赛车
就会知道哎这个点好像很重要对吧
所以我们经常讲的汽车调校
还有一个是什么呢
就是重心会对你的汽车的拐弯产生影响
一般来讲如果重心比较靠前
那你骑车拐弯的时候
它的转向力就不足
那为什么呢
其实很简单
大家还记得我们在学那个刚体动力学的时候
讲过
就是有一个叫那个转动惯量对吧
应该是那个叫那个那个叫什么来着
哎呦突然想不起转动惯量中文
Anyway
那么当那个就是重心靠前的时候啊
你会让相对于那个就是你的这个转动中心
那个转动惯量中心的时候
你的那个转向的利弊啊不够长
所以它的扭矩不够大
所以你的转向是不足的
这就是我们讲就是前驱车
因为发动机靠前导致它的转向不足
但是像一些跑车的时候
它的发动机会逐渐的往后靠
它的重心就往中间往中间一点
但这个时候呢它的它的驱动呢又在后面
它的导向呢就在前面
这个车的转向性能就会好于那些前驱车
其实就是这个道理
所以这里面也可以很容易地
用刚体动力学的方法可以讲出来
那其实这而且呢大家会注意
就是在我们在做一个真实的汽车模拟的时候
因为汽车这个弹性系统嘛
因为它车身的地方和那个车的几个轮子
它有个悬挂
因为这里面还有一个转动的关系对吧
所以它的重心呢会当我去加速的时候
重心会稍微的往后移那么一点点
大家如果自己开过车
就知道会有一种感觉
对我们经常讲的内容诶
好像感觉车子一加速
整个车头好像稍微抬那么一点点对吧
我减刹车的时候
你会觉得车头稍微按下去一点点
你的重心其实也有一点点的偏差
而这个东西的话呢
实际上在汽车的动力学模拟的时候
也是一个很重要的一个东西
叫WETRANSFER
对吧好
那这里呢给大家讲一个很有意思的东西
叫做这个就是那个就是argument的这个转向角
它实际上讲的意思是什么呢
就是如果我的汽车的两个导向轮
假设都打一样的方向角的时候
其实它外侧的轮呢实际上是空转的
它是在那被拖着走的
它的转向力其实是不足
所以呢它有一个数学的方法
就是内侧的轮它实际上转的更多一点
而外侧的轮呢转的稍微小
它指向是一个很远的一个旋转中心
然后呢以他那个连接线做垂线决定我的角度
这个非常的微妙
就是因为你的车本身是有宽度的汽车
如果同学没开过车
就知道车不像我们的人
我们的人可以这样来回这样运动
但车呢它是个刚体
所以当你做运动的时候
你其实要考虑到车自身的宽度
其实像这个ark米转向角的话呢
也是考虑到车是个缸体
也就是相对两个轮胎
它的前后关系是不能发生变化的
所以这个时候当你想让转向的时候
两边的导向轮都最大限度地发挥它的
转向作用的时候
它实际上是有一个小小的角度差的
大家不要觉得这种很高深啊
如果大家学的是汽车的工程学的话
这就是一个标配
就是现在所有的汽车它里面都有这个系统
所以才使得我们驾驶起来
觉得这个车诶好像很丝滑
但实际上人家做了一个非常精细的
一个数学运算
如果没有这个角度的处理的话
你会发现就是你的这个旋转的话
它会非常的不稳定
它就会变成一个螺旋衰减线
但是呢如果你有了这个arching这个角度的
这个叫嚣了
你就可以让这个车开出一个完美的弧线
怎么样
很有意思吧
其实其实我是觉得物理
数学这个东西非常的巧妙
然后呢它离我们的生活真的非常的近
而这个东西的话
当我们在做游戏的时候
你会发现你真的什么都要懂
我记得同学们在留言中在讲课
诶
最后一游戏引擎
怎么我什么都要明白
确实是这样的
因为我们干的活是什么
我们干的是上帝的活
我们在做一个就是人类世界的simulator
所以我们要符模拟几乎所有的物理规律
所以这个的话呢也是做汽车模拟
很关键的一个点
我们有了这些东西的时候
其实我们基本上就能模拟辆车
最后给大家讲一个东西是什么呢
就是说汽车的轮胎很多时候你会觉得很简单
我就是做一个简单的这样的一个recast
我就知道了高度
但实际上的话呢在真实的这个赛车游戏里面
我们都会用一个球
或者用一个圆去做这个sweeping
Sweeping
这样我就能知道跟这个环境真实的焦点在哪里
这样的话你的整个这个运动看上去的真真实
那么有了以上的这些所有的模型之后
你就用我们前面讲的那种弹簧质点对吧
速度这个惯性这些动力学
你其实就可以作为一个
非常简单的汽车模拟游戏了
而且这个东西非常的有意思
因为你调校它的每一个参数
比如说那个轮胎的摩擦力
发动机的扭矩和他那个发动机的扭矩
随着转速的变化曲线
包括你的重心的位置
你就可以做出各种各样不同质感的车了
其实我知道很多同学喜欢玩一种游戏
我不知道大家有没有玩过
就是说啊给你很多的building block
然后呢它有各种各样的物理的
这个比如说发动机的功率啊
它的摩擦力啊
一些连接关系啊
你做出各种各样的小机械
然后比比如说我们去竞速对吧
我们去这个互相打架
看谁把谁拆了
其实我个人是特别喜欢这种类型的游戏的
因为他给我无限的创造可能性
所以说VIP系统的话呢
它是真的能给大家带来这种感觉的一个系统
所以讲到这儿的话
我希望同学们应该大概知道
一辆一个车的模拟是怎么做的
但是呢如果我们自己不去写这个VIP系统
也没关系
你懂了这些概念之后
你去看一个标准的物理引擎里面
VIP系统的等于是AAPI的话
他基本上也是按照这个逻辑去构建
它几乎所有的接口
所以你接下来你要做的事情很简单
只需要调各个参数就可以了
这个就可以造出一辆你心仪的车
但是呢今天这个课程中啊
有些东西我们没有讲
举个简单的例子啊
虽然我们学会了这些V格系统
但我想问我们怎么去造一辆坦克呢对吧
坦克的下面是什么
是个履带
其实我们几乎所有的游戏
只要一做到坦克这件事情的话
大家都很头疼
因为坦克你想做的很真实的话
它还是蛮复杂的
因为你仔细看那个履带
他当你地上有一个有一个破破的东西的时候
它的履带还会变形
它那有些轮子可以上来就下来
然后呢有些是驱动轮对吧
而且它是左右转速不同
会导致这个这个坦克的转动
所以我就讲就是说真的在做物理型的时候
你做下去会有很多有意思的细节
包括在这节课中
我们没有讲解一个东西是什么叫飞行模拟
其实那个就是那个airplane的这种系统
我曾经有一次就是在国内一个非常著名的一个
飞行模拟的一个一个一个啊一个一个平台
我在那边看他们的后台系统
当时我们打开那个飞机的模拟的
那个物理参数的时候
当时我表示我已经完全看傻了
但是这些东西呢又是非常专业的
所以这也是物理引擎特别有意思的东西
非常希望大家有机会啊
钻下去就光光一个vehicle
光一个那个比如像坦克
像bot轮船
它的这个模型
船的模型
包括像那个飞机的模型对吧
其实就很有意思
讲到这的时候
大家是不是脑子中出现了啊
我们可以做一个叫海陆空一体的
这个一个战争模拟游戏了对吧
确实是我也是很喜欢这种游戏的
所以这里面有很多很有意思的
可以值得大家去遵义那个去钻研
那关于车呢
我们就讲到这儿了
好最后这一节课呢
我们最高能的一个part
就是说给大家介绍一些比较前沿的东西吧
叫什么叫PBD
什么叫XPPD对吧
这个听上去非常的高端
那首先的话呢传统的E呢
就跟大家就是挖挖这个
这个这个像祭拜一下仙人
那这里面我们不得不去膜拜一下
我们的数学界的这个这个先贤
就是这个拉格朗日
其实大家知道我们现在学的很多的力学
特别是在高中和阶段
我们学的都是什么
牛顿力学
像我讲的
你是用速度质点对吧
惯性加速度
好像匀速直线运动就能解释整个世界
但是呢这个其实从数学上看并不美妙
更像是一群工程师的想法
但是拉格朗日他的思维方式
就是有一套完全不一样的力学
叫拉格朗日力学
他的思维方式是这样
其实他把整个力学的规律描述成一系列的约束
然后呢他用约束去反向定义运动
他你会发现一个很巧妙的东西
就是说所有的运动都可以被反向运动规律吧
都可以被这些约束反向的求解回来
这件事情是非常了不起的
比如说我们假设要求你的这个约束
是这个动量守恒
实际上牛顿的这个啊应该是第一定律吧
就可以就可以直接退出来
你就必须是匀速直线运动
否则你的动量就是不守恒的
简单来讲就是这样的对吧
那么所以的话呢
就是那个拉格朗日的这个力学
是非常了不起的东西
特别是大家上大学之后
其实我也没有
大学的时候也没学过
因为我当时学的是啊计算机
但实际上如果大家学的是大学的高等物理的话
可能要接触到这些这些知识
那在我们的物理引擎里面
拉格朗日的这个力学对我们的帮助是什么呢
就是说他把我们很多力学的计算
变成了一个求解约束的问题
这里面给大家举一个比较简单的例子啊
大家还记得我们在上节课讲了一个
A匀速圆周运动嘛对吧
那这个运动我不管它是匀速还是不匀速啊
在这里面它其实有一个约束的
约束是什么呢
就是说这个点它始终绕着那个圆点不超过一
就是以围绕着距离为二的方向去去运动
那么其实我们要描述成一个就是约束
我要求它等于零对吧
我可以把这个运动描述成什么呢
就是X假设是他的那个位置
它的模减去二恒等于零
这是不是就它的约束
那在这里面的话
我对速度的约束是什么呢
速度是你这个关于空间位置的约束
把它对时间上求一个偏导
这个时候我对他求了个导
那么我对面dd t c x我就这个地方呢
我就用一个就是说我们的求导的展开对吧
这是属于我们叫枣树可以展开的这个原理
你会发现就是说我可以把它变成一个这个约束
关于空间位置的这个导数
就是DC到DX和这个DX到DT
DX到DT是什么呢
就是你的速度对吧
你会发现你的速度乘上前面就是那个那个约束
关于空间位置的这个导数
它两个乘积的话永远是零
但这里面其实比较复杂
它身上是个向量对吧
大家先脑补一下
而前面的这个约束关于空间位置的变化呢
这个东西是什么呢
就是大名鼎鼎的夹克比矩阵
其实我在讲那个动画的时候
讲AK的时候就讲过那个DKP取胜的存在对吧
在上一节课好像也提到了一点
讲课比之上
其实讲课比之上
我觉得真的是一个非常了不起的一个
数学的观察
就是说我我确实是没有办法用一个
用一个很简单很直接的话
给他解释他的这个数学
数学的这个直观的想象
在我的理解中
就是当我一个系统
比如大家想象一个教练
就是我想构建一个顶
我记得我上次说过
就是那我在思考
就是当我每个东西动那么一点点
动那么一点点之后
最后离我想要的结果
它到底是变得更近了
变得更远
这个趋势是什么
其实讲课比矩阵的话
更多的表达的是一个趋势的变化量
而这一点的话呢实际上是一个非常重要的
就是迭代法的一个一个思考题
大家如果学过牛顿迭代法
就是我一个方程式让我去解
我也不知道怎么去解怎么办
诶我随便先假猜测一个值
然后呢我求在那个点上的导数
那个导数呢就是表示这个值我对他扰动一点点
它的趋势是什么好
我就朝着那个最靠近我那个趋势的方向去
德尔塔X德尔塔X德尔塔X居家
最终我会加到那个点
所以这个夹克比矩阵
你可以认为它就是一个对这个
对这个约束的一个导数
在那个点上的导数
他就告诉你说
你如果想下一步尝试的时候
你沿着这个方向尝试
你以最快的速度就能收敛到我那个点
其实它最简单的一个数学解释
就是这个解释其实不是数学
我觉得是我个人发明的一个空间学姐
因为我是一个很依赖于空间想象的一个人
就是你让我真的对一堆数学公式我会很崩溃
但是呢你让我去面对诶
一个空气上的一个弹簧啊
一个支点
一个什么东西的时候
诶
我会想象的特别好
那么其实对于弹簧质点模型里面
你也可以一样的用这种约束去表达
你会发现当你有两个支点XX2的时候
他可以乱动
对不对
但是它中间应该反满足
这个就是他要回到他的Rest pose
那么实际上它的约束是什么呢
就是X1减X2
它两个之间的距离就是那个模长诶
他减那个他我们的Rest pse那个距离它等于零
这就是我对一个弹簧的约束
那么我怎么去有了这些约束东西的时候
我怎么去迭代去找他的点呢
这里面就要去讲一下一个大名鼎鼎的PPT的
这个思想其实刚才我讲的夹克比矩阵对吧
那么假设我一开始有这个点
所有的点在空间上就是X1234
56789 11
直到N
那么实际上呢
我认为他这个所有的约束为零的那个状态
以以那个我们右边的图为例啊
就是那个实现的那个形状
但我现在很不幸
我在他最外面那个点对吧
你会发现啊
就是说你求出这个函数的这个讲课比矩阵
哎呀这个地方就讲解来比较复杂了
这个这个方面
其实我一点点的讲还是蛮有意思的
但是呢它最简单的一个理解
就是说在我当前那个点的话
我去求他一个夹克比矩阵
我就知道他的那个取倾向性是什么
它就往哪儿去指
然后呢接下来呢我就要猜我的步伐
那个number mea到底是多少
然后呢
当我就是永远沿着那个那个他的那个切线
那个就是那个应该叫倒垂直那个方向走一个
我认为它应该的步长去逼近
我要的那个就是你所有的约束都为零的那个点
其实这个东西啊
在解那个就是IK的时候也是一样的
就当我人身上有很多的joint对吧
每个教练都会自己动啊
我要往这边来一点
每个joint都会自己动
当我到这个点的时候
其实你可以理解成
就是我每个join都试着去动一下对吧
每个角
那我其实用一个讲课比矩阵
它就会告诉我一个趋势
说如果你想go这个点的话
你这个joint得收起来
你这个专业可能要去打开
你这个专业可能也要打开
这个时候你就能够到上面这个点
实际上讲课比起传套话
他能算出就是在当前的这个姿态下
你要想靠近你的目标点的话
你每一个约就每一个变量
他应该去扰动的趋势是什么
但这个趋势呢当你的扰动量变大的时候呢
他这个趋势就不准了对吧
所以呢它会有一个number mea的步长的计算
而在我们的PPT里面的话呢
我们最核心的思想就是说我们不去算速度了
我们也不算什么加速度
我们也不算什么力
什么都不算
我们只算一个事情
就是说你把所有的这种物理系统
都描述成一系列复杂的关于你位置的约束
因为你就以那个医疗为例吧
它实际上你本质上
这个医疗是有一系列的约束构成的
对不对
那我用夹克比矩阵去算它
在每一个当前的pose下
我应该往哪个方向扰动
我就一直扰动扰动扰动
但是每一次我都动一点点
动一点点之后呢
我再去算我是不是满足这个约束
如果不满足的话
我把这个过程再重复一遍
所以大家可以把就是对这个PPT的理解啊
在我看来就是一个啊超级的牛顿迭代法
但是它的核心思想呢
用的是拉格朗日力学的方法
就是说把所有的比如说碰撞也好呀
惯性也好耶
加速度也好
全部我不管你372 11
我全部把你变成了一组的约束的
这个这个这个这个这个矩阵
然后呢我求出你的这个这个趋势
然后呢沿着你的趋势去不停的去扰动
你的每个顶点
就这么个思想
就是你可以认为它像套圈
一圈圈圈圈圈去逼近那个结果
所以它是个迭代式算法
那么PPT最核心的一个点就在于
就是说他因为把所有的物理学的规律
都抽象成约束了
包括比如像碰撞
它也是把它变成一个约束了
那你以前在解这种牛顿力学的这种速度啊
加速这些
可能会导致你的这个iteration或者simulation
不稳定的东西的话
把它给优化掉
所以真实的这个数学啊讲讲起来就比较复杂了
那我们诶有一个传统的异能是什么
就是听大家的意见
在这节课一开始的时候
同学们就讲课
说要求我们提供参考资料
所以呢我们在这个这个课件的后面几页
就会把PPT详细的这个这个文章啊发出来
因为PPT
它其实最早的篇章应该是2007年的文章
那篇文章还发表了一个非常小的会议上
但是确实是一个非常巧妙的思想
那么就是说哎呀我的天呐
这个地方就很高能了
就是实际上啊你要算那个德尔塔
其实这里面你可以看到
就是说啊这个公式里面的话呢
啊
你就算你每一个顶点应该往前移动的
一个小小的步长
而它的德尔塔X的那个方向呢
就是德尔塔X是所有的定点的移动啊
它实际上是沿着这个甲克比矩阵的方向
跟他的那个讲课比值的那个模长之间
一个二次方的比
这个公式其实啊我自己是真的推导过的
还蛮有意思的
一步一步的推下来
其实特别好玩
就是它本质上是要解个什么方程
就是这边就是说我在C的XK
加上一个德尔塔X之后
这个约束他还是尽可能的逼近零
它这个里面他做了一部简化
就是我先把这个C的X加DX呢用泰勒展开
把它展开了
然后把高阶项全部扔掉
因为有些是德尔塔X的平方
有的DX3次方
一般在我们这种就是说在simulation的时候
我们认为德尔塔克非常的小
所以我们会把高阶全部扔掉
然后接下来我们就去求说啊
那我这个德尔塔到底是多少呢
诶他又假设了一件事情
就是说我德尔塔的方向
一定是沿着一个亚克比矩阵的那个
切线方向去走
所以我认为我是我要选择我要走的步长
拉姆达到底是多少
然后呢他把这个东西呢反向了再带回来诶
就得到了这样的一个方程
这样的方程的话你就会发现你消消消
你就可以反向的算出来我的number a是多少
算出了NELA
我又知道了我要走的方向
你把NELA乘上
那个他的那个就是那个雅克比矩阵
给定的那个方向的话
实际上就是我们要的这个这个疑似迭代了补偿
其实整个PPT就是这个算法
我本来不想讲解那个数学的
但是其实这个公式呢
如果大家学过这个高等的这个
偏分分的东西的话
大概能看得明白
包括如果大家读原文的话
其实这是我认为它最核心的一个思想
所以PPT呢你去理解它实际上是蛮简单
这是一个非常经典的PPT的一个一个代码
你可以发现就是你的约束会在变
你的环境在变
但是呢它基础的循环不会变
一上来我就是按照这个step去iteration
那首先在每一部里面的话呢
我先把这个就是说所有的这个V
把所有的V全放上去
这里面是做了一个就是半音式的积分
然后接下来呢我去算我把地方全变了的时候
我看有没有碰撞
如果有碰撞的话
本质上就等于是我给你这个系统加了一个约束
就是说我第一步因为我知道你当前的位了对吧
我知道你的这个这个上一帧的位置了
我其实可以算出我当前这一阵的位置
对不对
但是我当前这个位置算出来的时候呢
实际上很多时候可能是有问题的
他可能有穿插对吧
他可能钻到地下去了
我这样的话呢
我用这个这个general collection的话呢
把这些科生的约束也也算出来了
好这个时候我就有两组约束了
第一组约束是什么
是我布料
以布料为例啊
我布料本身我的这个不能被拉升的这个约束
对不对
还有一个什么呢
还有就是说我不能够这个这个这个穿模
我不能够这个这个这个就是说自我碰撞
这个约束
这约束我也放进去了
好接下来就开始用刚才那个那个方法
就是那个我我认为叫做用夹克比矩阵的
超级的这个打个双引号的这个牛顿迭代法
我就开始每一次按照一个number补偿去迭代
直到两个结果
哪两个结果呢
一就是我真的把这个所有的constrain的这个
这个这个误差小于某个我给定的epsilon
一个小的值
就这个迭代会一直下去
或者说呢哎哎呀大哥
你已经迭代了十几部了
也差不多了
别再闹了
那就不迭代了
就放在这了对吧
那么这两个终止条件我们就停止接单
这个时候其实我们就会算出
真正的我们认为在这一帧的情况下
你应该停留的位置在哪里
你应该就是获得的这个就是这个速度在哪里
那我们呢还会基于这个速度给它加一个dumpling
那为什么这个dumpling很重要呢
因为就是刚才也讲过
就是这个系统的话
如果不加上一个速度的dumpling的话
这个PPT的这个这个server很可能会不稳定
会炸掉
大家可以试一下
把这个地方关掉对吧
我自己呢这个PPT我是没写过的
但是呢我在读他的原文的时候
他就反复强调这个事情
就是说这个dumpling是一定要加的好
但是PPT呢其实是一个非常呃
现在来讲是越来越热的一个东西
特别是像医疗的模拟的话
基本上都在用PPT这个思想也可以理解成
就是说早期的物理引擎
比如说这次我们给大家接的那个joint引擎
它还是传统的这个基于这个就是顶点
基于速度的物理引擎
但PPT引擎就是说PPT
他就说用影视的这种约束的方法去解它的好处
就是说它整个这个解第一个收敛会很快
第二个呢它比较稳定
不太容易出现异异常的情况
比如像在布料系统里面的话
PPT是一个非常重要的一个方法
基本上大家现在都在用PPT了
那么懂了这个知道PPT的概念的话呢
其实XPPT就不太难懂了
XPT呢这个东西呢现在也慢慢的越来越火
这也是现在物理引擎一个比较前沿的一个方向
比如说像虚幻五
他自己猛推的
属于自己的那个chaos的那个物理引擎的话
他自称就是用的XPPT
那么XPPT呢
你可以理解成就是个PPT的一个优化
就是说他在这个PPT中间引入了一个量
这个量叫做stiffness
就是说我的这个约束它到底是一个硬约束
还是个软约束
注意啊
这里面很有意思
就是说他的这个SYPHUS的话
在那个地方
如果这个约束如果是个零
那个STEPHENCORE是零的话
它的它的导数就是1÷0才是无穷大
就表示我这个约束非常的STEVE
你别惹我
你惹我
我就把你的能量给你直接炸掉对吧
如果我这个东西其实是可以软软的
没关系
你可以有足够大的弹性和误差的时候
我的这个stiffness是相对小一点
所以它有点抽象
所以他写进去的时候
都是会用阿尔法和阿尔法的那个导数
就是阿尔法的那个一来做
那么其实呢
这个时候我们如果以前的一个方程又优化了
那个那个那个就是约束方程是CX的话呢
其实我自己对PXPPT的理解啊
在这里面的话
我只能必须得承认我的理解还比较粗浅
但是大家可以顺着这个思路去看下去
实际上我认为它是把这个以前的约束方程
升格成了一个叫做compliance matrix
就是叫服从度矩阵
这个矩阵呢其实是什么样的
就是下面写到的这个UX
这个UX的话呢
它实际上你可以认为就是他把CX和CX的转置
中间
把他的STENNESS沉进去了
然后前面加了个1/2
这个玩意儿
其实看上去好像大家觉得很奇怪
这个一个变化之后
为什么他就诶有点意思了
我给大家一个最简单的我个人的土法理解啊
其实我是特别喜欢用土法理
去理解一个高深的算法
大家想象一下
如果你把这个约束想象成一个弹簧
那么这个stiffness
你可以把它理解成就是弹簧的硬度对吧
就是它为零的时候
这个弹簧硬度就无穷大
那么它的导数就是虎克常数
那么CX是什么呢
就是那个那个偏移量就或者叫做误差
你可以理解成位移
那么一个弹簧它的误差偏移量多少的时候
是不是就是二分之1KX平方
大家可以推导一下
一个弹簧所储存的势能
就是你把它从Rest pose拉开来的位移的平方
但是如果这个不是一个单一维的弹簧
它可能是个多维的系统的时候
实际上你把他这个约束
就会变成一个矩阵的形式
那矩阵乘以矩阵的转置
中间再加上一个这样的一个STEFFNESS的话
实际上他从他的这个这个数学的逻辑上
其实你可以认为
就是说这个系统内涵的一种势能
它本质上就是让你去优化
让这个势能足够的小
但是这个XPPT
它有一个很大的好处是什么呢
就是说它可以给逐条的约束
增加它的这个stiffness
简单来讲
就比如说像这里面展示的一个案例
就是那个硬币在来回的抖动对吧
他这个约束呢就是一个非常硬的约束
这个时候他身边的就会射的很高
你能看到那种非常合理的这种高频的抖动
大家知道其实在传统的物理模拟里面
刚提模拟里面这个case是比较难解决的
那么但是呢对于比如说软的木料啊
软的布料
或者是一些我们叫做一个一个一个一个
比如说软软的这种
柔性的或者可塑性的形体的话
这个STEPHENIST我就可以放得比较弱
而这些东西放到一起之后
特别是布料对吧
我是比较柔软的
所以有些约束我其实可以约束的轻一点
那我就可以在一个方程里面
根据对每条约束设定它的stiffness的话
我就可以一个方程把它解出来
这其实是我个人认为XPPPPD最大的好处
这方面的话呢实际上有很多的专家
其实那个啊那个就是说大家去看那个太极嘛
就昨天我还跟那个胡彦明在讲
我说哎
我们可以Q1下你们的太极的这个课程对吧
那实际上在他们那边的话呢
其实PPTXPPT的这个SL的话
实际上是啊一个很重要的一个
这个这个就是说这个语言的application
那么简单来讲的话呢
就是XPPT在现代的游戏引擎里面的话呢
已经越来越popular
这也是我们现在也比较关注的一个方向
那么但是呢很遗憾的就是说
这个东西是刚刚这两年兴起的
还没有经过工业化的大规模检验
其实我们也在看
比如说这个算法的稳定度
这个算法的这个数值的可控性和精度
是不是能保证住
包括在对于游戏各种各样复杂的场景
因为游戏对这个物理式的表达
它不仅是物理的模拟的真实性
还有很多的可控性
那么这一点的话呢
实际上也是啊现代物理引擎
一个比较前沿的一个发展方向
所以这里面很那个我们的数学就不展开了
大家记住
这里面引入了一个complex match matrix
在我的理解中
这个matrix的话是一个势能的一种表达
基本上讲到这个的话呢
我们物理的两节课终于讲完了
讲的我又是嗓子哑了
我先喝口水
然后终于到了大家最喜闻乐见的环节了
就对吧
大家天天问我们说要么不作业
那好吧
那既然我们憋了四节课才会布一次作业的话
那这个作业的那个量就不会太小
那我们这次这个作业呢
就是基于我们前四节课讲的物理和动画
会把那个jolt引擎接进去给大家
那我们希望大家做
就是一个基础作业和一个就是高级作业
技术作业
作业呢
我们希望同学们在引擎中实现一个小小的
动画的混合系统
一个动画的状态机
大家还记得我们在上一节课讲课的
这个animation state machine嘛
对不对
那这里面的话
你看这个角色从慢走走向正常的走到快跑
然后还能跳一下
大家还记得在我们的动画的状态机里面讲过
你比如说这个角色走跑跳跳起来在landing
其实这里面有很多的动画的这个blending的问题
那么这个肯定是要用到steam machine的
那么这些动画的素材呢我们会提供给大家
那希望大家的话呢
能够在我们的小引擎中实现一个
非常简单的角色的这样的一个状态机
那么第二个呢
课程呢就是我们想提的一个需求啊
一个要求就是大家实现一个最简单的
Character controller
那么大家知道就是刚才我讲课就是KKCTRL
有很多属性
比如说我走到墙上的话
我不会把它挡住
而是我能一路滑过去
对不对
而且我也不会穿墙而过
那这里面还有很多的小细节
举个例子啊
比如说这个角色跳起来撞到墙了
如果这个control做得不够好
你会发现那个角色就整个吸在墙上
墙上去了
因为物理已经不会告诉你这个人会掉下来了
对吧
诶你这个时候还要能让它自己的滑下来
所以这样的话就是还有一点
就是
比如说我们的世界会做的很多的
起起伏伏的东西嘛
这个角色在走的时候
在跳的时候
比如说他跳起来
他就能真的落到一个表面上
而现在的我们的那个就是啊
游戏在小引擎中的实现的话
如果我没记错的话
应该是非常粗暴的一个recasting
所以的话呢我希望同学们用control的思想
实现一个真正的control
所以的话这也是我们从6月1号开始对吧
哎呀不好意思
真的好坏啊
6月儿童节给大家补作业
而且同学们现在还有这个考试
我知道很多同学期末考试
很多同学有毕业设计
毕业季毕业设计应该已经做完了
那么大家如果有兴趣的话呢
可以在未来的这个这个就是几周里面
去挑战一下这个作业
因为这个作业你如果做完之后的话
就表示你真的懂了这个动画系统
真的懂了
物理系统怎么用
那真的就是一个游戏引擎的使用的基础
那么最后那个大家如果有任何问题的话
大家也不要紧张
就是说到我们的课程的官网上
直接问我们的课程组
因为不论是我这边没有跟大家讲清楚
课程题目是什么呀
还是说大家真的不知道怎么下手的话
不要不好意思
直接找我们课程组
课程组帮忙
我们会帮大家去解决这些问题
那最后的话呢就跟大家分享一下
我们最喜闻乐见的部分了
就是我们的reference了
终于我们的104开始有reference
那我们呢课程组的小伙伴还是很用心的
把今天讲的character controller
Rock door
所有的论文放在这了
还有呢就是大家讲的这个class系统的论文
也放在这了对吧
然后呢还有我们的破坏系统论文也放在这了
对吧
居然还有中文的资料
然后呢还有什么呢
还有我们的这个微课系统也放在这了
还有刚才讲的这个特别高端的PPT系统
也放在这了
所以同学们如果对我们今天讲的任何一趴
感兴趣的话
就可以在这里面去找到你想要的资料
这个也会以后也会成为我们games
104的一个惯例吧
我们就在这边立个flag
争取每节课都给同学们提供一个详细的
我们的reference文档
因为这些文档确实在我们准备课课程中的话
都是认真的读过
认真的理解过
确保我们给大家讲的东西
在我们的能力之下尽可能的正确
OK好
那今天的课程就到这儿了
那个说实话
我们课程组的小伙伴真的非常的辛苦
我现在都有点不好意思了
就是那个很多时候怎么说呢
我认为他们花的精力比我多很多很多
很多才能准备一个这么高质量的课程
我自己也非常的感动
那那么就是我们一起感谢一下他们的好
那就是今天我的课程的全部
同学们有没有什么问题
我先喝口水
好的同学们有什么问题吗
啊哇哈第一个问题就好难
同学问我说
为什么游戏里的布娃娃会鬼畜啊
这个问题呢其实就两点吧
第一点的话呢就是说刚才我也讲了
就是如果那个joint它做的不够好的话
很容易产生鬼畜的结果
但是joint约束就算做好了之后
会不会产生鬼会的
因为在真实的游戏世界里面啊
一个布娃娃系统
它的初始的这个运动
很多时候是动画系统输入给他的
动画系统就在我们前面
第一节课讲那个讲物理的时候
讲课是动画驱动的这个东西的运动
它是个CONDEMIC物体
就是说它是一个反物理学的一个东西
他输出的例句
输入的那个就是他的那个impose
有可能在某种计算机下会变成无穷大
另外一个的话呢
就是说我真实的物理世界有大量的这种
比如说actor
他们是符合物理规律的时候
比如说特别像静态的vector
静态factor在这个你去撞他的时候
你可以认为它的那个就是整个质量
和它的那个动量是无穷大的
所以你会发现很多的REACD的东西
它一旦进入到一个复杂的环境里面
就是你比如说你社死了一个角色
你把这个角色调到一个很小的一个
一个坑道里面
那他整个RAGDOLL的行为就会非常的奇怪啊
因为有的时候RAGDOLL的约束的话
他让这个人一定会穿过
那个就没办法装进那个狭小的区间
但是呢他又不小心某一帧他就进去了
进去了之后在里面就是这个它的物理的SIMILATION
它就会不稳定
其实物理的simulation的稳定
实际上是一个非常难的一个问题
所以在我们的就是我经常讲解
就是我们所有的物理解算都是iteration对吧
但是真正好的物理引擎
或者说一个做物理引擎功率很高的人
它就在于我什么时候stop iteration就停在那儿了
但是stop停的不好的话
你会出现一个就是我们经常讲的就是一个东西
正好卡在一半
卡得住了
好
你一旦卡上去了
你后面除非你给他
就其实你后面给他加再大的力
至少在物理引擎里面
你是没办法
他两个分开了
很多时候我们得high的把他们两个分开了
其实我们以前在做角色的时候
经常会出现
就是这个碰撞
这个物理仿真没解决好之后
一个角色就卡在一个地方
他就是也是这个原因
所以RAGDOLL的话呢
因为这个这些所有的action的运动
全是交给物理模拟的
所以有很很有可能会卡在一个地方
或者说很有可能会产生一些
就是没有办法dumpling掉的这种扰动
这个这种很奇怪的速度量
惯性量
然后在里面来回的系统里面震荡
就震荡来震荡去
第二个问题是同学问
我说就是爆炸和可破坏物体之间的
交那个交互啊
其实这个东西呢它是由两部的
不是一步完成的
就是当我们在游戏的game play系统里面说
这个地方发生了一个爆炸之后呢
一般我们会有一个叫爆炸区域
爆炸区域呢
一般它是一个沿着中心衰减的一个冲量场
大家这个很好理解吧
就是我在靠中间的地方冲量就很大
越靠你旁边冲量就越小
当我有一个另外一个可破坏物体
他受到了这个就是它检测到了
说我在爆炸区域里面之后
它其实可以根据你的爆炸的这个
这个离爆炸中心的距离算出自己的冲量
刚才我们已经讲了
就是说你有了一个冲量之后
我可以根据你的HARDLESS
就算出你的这个这个
这个破坏的那个系数是多少对吧
就是其实就是冲量除杀哈德斯
然后那个值如果大于我们一开始预设的那个
就是每一个chunk之间的那个connection
那个最大的容忍度的话
那这个时候就发生它整个碎裂或者破坏了
这个问题有点难
有同学问我说有没有实时的音效模拟
它到底算不算物理模拟啊
实际上的话呢
声音系统和物理系统是两个系统
基本上我们没有
我没有看到一个物理引擎里面它会带声音系统
但是今天为什么我会提到声音和particle呢
就是说其实这里面就引就引出了
就是物理引擎
如果我们自己做物理引擎的时候
有个很重要的机制叫call back
是他是什么意思呢
就是说当我在某一帧就某一个事件发生的时候
我一定要交给其他这个引擎
一个回调的一个能力
就是说我知道
比如说呃我现在把这个雕像炸成了十几块
那当这些碎片自己之间发生碰撞
或者碎片撞到地上或者某一个环境物体的时候
我会有一个产生这样的一个call back
告诉我说诶你到底撞到什么东西
你撞到它的力量角度点在哪里
这个时候其实是交给这个引擎自己去决定
说我是不是产生一个particle
我是不是产生一个音效对吧
那么在很多时候呢
我们不会做的这么精细
但是在某些特殊的场合的时候
比如说你真的离得特别特别近
或者说呢这个东西特别特别的巨大
那么一些对于比较大的一些碎块的话
我们确实要做一个
比如说这个石头砸到地上的那个声音
包括他们自身碰撞的声音
那这个系统的话呢
它是两个非常分开的系统去处理的
但是呢中间是通过我们的游戏引擎
把它们连到一起去
那么这个call back也不是说你每次产生意见
产生事件
它就call back
实际上有也
你可以是这一帧整个物理模拟完之后
我一个query
把所有的这种collision的事件全部拿到也可以的
就是你如果catch的那边对吧
所以它是两个系统
哇这个同学问的问题很有意思
他说如果我要让物理系统非常的符合现实
那还需要用的controller吗
实话实说
如果极度的现实的话
就不应该有control了
因为我们人的移动的话
不是因为跟汽车一样
就是我们身体输出一个扭矩
在我们的脚上和地面
脚跟轮胎一样
形成了一个一个摩擦力对吧
让我的整个人往前走
那原则上来讲的话
用物理引擎
你可以把东西全部都做一遍的
但是事实上的话呢
在游戏中的话呢
我们一般不会这么做
所以这这里面其实就引发了一个
非常经典的一个一个辩论
就是说我们在游戏引擎中
是不是物理模拟做的越真实
越细腻越好
我个人的答案是NO
因为就是说因为我以前在做科研的时候
我们经常会跟ground truth去比
比如说一个小球
一个烟过去
然后沿着烟形成一个很漂亮的形状对吧
一个小船在水里面
就用那个就是那个那个那个never choke那个方程
让它模拟各种水面的波动都很好看
但实际上呢当我们在游戏的时候
我个人一直认为游戏的核心
它是一个趣味性的东西
它是一个playable的东西
所以是一个用户自我表达的东西
所以他对世界的模拟我认为是达到一个精度
它能反映出用户的需求就可以了
而过度追求物理的那种仿真的无限细节的话
实际上在有就从根本的角度来讲
我认为有的时候它是一种destruction
就是一种干扰
比如说我们经常会看到有些3A大作
它的整个战场环境做的非常的细腻
非常的复杂
对啊烟尘满天飞啊
气氛感足足的
但是你真的玩这个游戏的时候
你发现除了一开始觉得他很酷啊
但是你玩起来你觉得这个游戏不是特别好玩
因为你大家回想一下
我们在真实的世界里
我们真实世界是上帝写的模拟器
它的模拟精度应该是百分之百
对不对
但是99%的时候
你并不会不会觉得这个世界很好玩对吧
那其实呢在游戏世界里面也是一样的
所以我认为就是说在游戏引擎里面
这个物理模拟它实际上是一种表达
足够就可以了
而不需要过度追求它的这个细腻度和仿真度
但追求细腻度的仿真度呢
在很多比如说像cg对吧
就是电影的影视动画里面
这个要求确实是非常高的
他真的要求的非常非常的细
但很多时候我们会用离线渲染的方法去表达它
哇这个问题问的好挑战啊
他说你没研究过虚幻里面五里面
上万个碎片是怎么优化的
呃实话实说
那一趴我还没有用
还没看到哈
就是还没有真的去优化
但是我在虚幻五里面
我看了一下它的整个效能啊
就是呃它一个很重要的就是那个GPU particle
还有很多的物理的那种碎片的particle
但是我看到的情况是
他们那个一旦这些东西全开了之后
帧率掉的还是蛮厉害的
就是虚幻五目前的版本好像还是很吃性能的
但是优化的话呢你要仔细看他的话呢
我猜大概率可能就是把它扔到很多核并行计算
因为其实物理的很多运算它全部是可以并行的
包括甚至我可以用GPU追问的方法
用一些GPU方法去加速它
但真实的从物理算法来讲的话呢
我觉得如果你选择了
就是说牛顿力学的就是顶点速度法
或者是用的PPT算法
或者他那个cos自己说的XP算法的话呢
SA本身的话呃
应该它的性能应该是基本上是会定在那了
但是呢你可以在很多的hack
很多的trick把它优化
所以简单来讲的话
这一趴我没有看过
但是我目前自己的体感
就是至少从他的几个demo上来看的话
他的有些demo的这个帧率还是有很大的一个
提高的空间
好的
是不是就这些问题了
好的好
那谢谢大家
那我们那个两周后见
今天我们终于完成了一个大的section
然后呢
我们下一那个下下周在新的章节界面
好
谢谢大家